[Music]
homie look what I become
what no no the Eminem that he talks
about purple pills anyways podcast is
like we're talking about purple pills
special podcast here for you uh uh I've
been very excited about this one here
for a couple different reasons Our Guest
today let me formally introduce them
before we get right into it this man
when you see his face you're going to
think of something else but you have to
know one thing about this man
um he was on the honor roll every term
in high school I don't know if you guys
know this or not every term in high
school badass wrestler
uh badass wrestler in a Missouri State
uh high school activities then he went
and became you know Association state
championships as a senior in wrestling
aside from that he goes to Bellator he
knows how to email and turn a girlfriend
into a wife we need to kind of figure
that out for a couple of these guys here
Mike if we can teach you some lessons
trying to make him a red purple pill we
don't have referencing Eminem but I'm
gonna take this here here's here's for
me so a couple things when I watch you
man one I think today
if if I was to say you know like if I
want to watch basketball I want to watch
Steph Curry play to me he's exciting you
know if I wanted John Laurent is
exciting to me certain people are
exciting to me certain people are not
exciting to me those guys are exciting
right like you wanted to watch Michael
play you wanted to watch certain people
play judge just hit her 60 seconds
watching certain players play
if this guy's my when you're fighting I
have to watch your fights I would say
the most exciting fighter today period I
like watching you fight it doesn't
matter if it was Justin or you against
Charles either one of them could have
gone your way Charles could have even
been stopped some of the fights have
been stopped in those types of
situations but in my opinion you can
crucify me you can come after me I think
he's the most exciting fighter right now
to watch with that being said Michael
Chandler in the house goodness thank you
well number one thank you for having me
on number two thank you for those those
kind words because that is uh it's the
goal right AB is a small guy from a
small town and somehow I ended up here
on the Patrick David show so here we are
let's go you know what I like when
you're being interviewed I kind of share
this with the with the uh on Instagram
where you know they're hey you know the
money fight's going to be Connor but you
got this and you know listen man my
entire life I've been chasing to be the
champion my entire every training
everything I do 24 7. I'm doing this to
be the champion yes I understand I'm
going to make more money with the other
one let's just say because it's a money
fight I have to be a champion once I
become a champion then I'm gonna go do
the fight so it's so obvious you're so
Crystal Clear on what your target is
what you're going after uh and and for
you you know you you came in you've been
in Bellator so some of the audience that
doesn't know if you don't mind taking a
moment and just kind of share your
background on how you got into fighting
wrestling and then typically a wrestler
is not a good stand-up but you got a
great stand up some fights you don't
even want to wrestle yeah and you know
how to wrestle so maybe tell everybody a
little bit about your story yeah I just
um you know I was I was an undersized
kid from from High Ridge Missouri didn't
have hair under my armpits until I was
almost 18 years old you know so I always
had to create scrape and Claw for
everything that I had
um I obviously wasn't going to be the
Star Quarterback or this or the the you
know the starting center on the the
basketball team so weight classes and
the sport of wrestling seemed like the
easiest path to uh find success so I
started wrestling in high school I was
the first one that really took it
seriously and on my high school team
wrestled
365 days a year basically and I was the
first one that had done that and since
then Northwest High School has turned
into a year-round program where those
guys are you know wrestling all year
long in St Louis in St Louis Missouri
they got my picture of me as an
All-American up there and and those guys
kind of strive and say hey and the
coaches say hey if you want to be
successful if you want to be great you
can't just be a Wandering generality
because if the same coaches or the new
coach uh same coaches one one of them is
one of them's retiring this year Ron and
Bob wilhouse
um so one of them is retiring this year
and then one will continue to stay on
and then
um I actually I fell short I went to
went to the state champions for state
championships four different times in
high school qualified every single year
made it to the finals my senior year but
fell short every single year I wasn't
wasn't a state champion I placed one
year so I still had that competitive
that competitive itch and I got some
smaller school offers D1 or D2 D3 and AI
but something in me for some reason said
hey if you're gonna go wrestle at the
next level you need to wrestle at the
highest level take that chance so I
ended up walking on to the University of
Missouri uh wrestling program I was the
lowest guy on the totem pole coach
didn't talk to me for an entire year
everybody got three sets of workout gear
I got one set of workout gear which
meant more laundry and you know yeah uh
you you just felt like you were
overlooked and I knew I had to put in
the extra hours I put in the extra hours
ended up becoming a team captain and
All-American and then still had the
competitive itch but didn't want to
continue to wrestle I was very fortunate
Tyron Woodley Ben ashken I wrestled with
both of those guys at Mizzou they
started fighting and they were like my
big brothers and I said well I'm not
ready to get a job you know and use my
degree quite yet so let me go ahead and
just uh start fighting okay your shirt I
have a list of questions that I want to
ask yeah right like I I the first
question I had I was like I need to
understand this and it's basically how
these athletes fall through the cracks
right and you can go to any sport NFL
Tyreek Hill arguably the best wide
receiver in the league went to what have
you state right so I'm hearing your
resume and ironically you're wearing the
shirt walk on and essentially the
concept of my question was all these
amazing athletes they show up out of
nowhere and like Pat read your your
resume very eloquently right honor roll
every year football player a wrestler
you're the Team MVP All-City St Louis
right but no scholarship no big school
wanted you on the on the team right you
walked on like honestly like Rudy
rudiger style literally yeah like 100
you know 100 and nothing five foot
nothing whatever the hell it is
um by the time you're a senior in
college you're All-American so a lot of
people these days you know want to get
rich quick or they want to kind of you
know have success quick and essentially
one of the things I always talk about is
like yeah you got to work your ass off
bro you got to pay your dudes like you
kind of got to go through some [ __ ] to
kind of realize what it's like at the
top so I kind of understand is that
mindset is it just you know stick to
itness it's just like you're you know
it's not the size of the uh the dog in
the fight it's the size of the uh
fighting the dog what do you owe your
success to bro honestly I think patience
and and
stick-to-itiveness to realize that yes I
wanted to be a state champion yes I
wanted to be an All-American I wanted to
be a national champion I wanted to be
able to beat Jordan Burroughs that
wasn't in the cards for me now granted
it could have been in the cards for me
if I was winning the battle between my
ears I realized when I graduated college
I took fifth as a senior
um when I took when I took those straps
off the singlet for the last time I went
back to we were at the Sabbath Center or
Edward Jones or Sabbath Center in St
Louis immediately all that pressure came
off of me and I thought you know what I
underperformed so badly over the last
five years because I put so much
pressure on myself and it wasn't that
big of a deal I did everything right if
coach said run through that brick wall I
would be the first one through that
brick wall and I would break that wall
down if he said to 100 reps I'm doing
200 if you said work four hours I'm
working six hours I was the guy who I
was that guy who came in and did
everything so I was doing everything
right physically and I was building up
this body I was doing all the workouts I
was putting in all the Reps but what I
was not doing was taking ownership and
extreme ownership of my self-image
because an individual will never be able
to outperform a poor self-image and that
was the story of me because once again
as I alluded to in the very beginning I
was a small guy from a small town who
was taught to do small things and there
was that's nothing against my upbringing
my town the people that I was around I
was just I wasn't taught that outside
those county lines you can go out there
and not just do something good but you
can do something great and do something
extraordinary and I bought into that
loud what is that kind of how it was
where that's the mindset yeah some way
you know and and it wasn't necessarily
it it was it was inherent it wasn't even
it wasn't even talked to me it wasn't as
if my parents told me you know hey
you're not going to amount anything I
had amazing parents an amazing amazingly
supportive parents but they didn't build
in in me enough to believe that I could
go out there and do something great and
if I fall flat on my face at least I
tried and that was that's why I thank
God every day that I did somehow make
that decision that I was going to walk
on to Mizzou because I could have taken
the scholarship to Missouri Baptist or
Central Missouri State one of these
smaller schools and best case scenario I
win a national title as a sophomore and
then think well shoot I under now I'm
under achieving because I should have
went division one I'd rather go division
one ride the pine ride the bench quit
after a couple years not make it get
injured be a be a perennial backup every
year and train at the train and compete
at the highest level than to become a
national champion in a smaller Big Fish
small Punk big fish pop on and here we
are I'm just just over what two years
and two weeks into my UFC run now and I
had that I had that Moment of clarity
finally where I I thought about the 40
year old Michael
who's laying next to my beautiful wife
Bree and that pillow that I'm laying my
head on feels like a 40 pound sandpaper
cinder block because I can't sleep
because I didn't take the chance I
didn't walk on and walk out of Bellator
the smaller organization to go on and
give myself the opportunity to get on
the biggest platform possible and I did
and it's sure is working out well so fat
what's the story you always tell about
you know the greatest general of all
time yeah that story that's exactly
would you share that with him it's kind
of the uh the concept yeah I think I
understand where you're going with it
the whole the guy dies goes to heaven
you know asking Saint Peter who was the
greatest general of all time he says it
was you but you never took the shot when
we send the recruiter you always wanted
to be the greatest General you were
afraid you didn't make the decision you
would have gone in you would have been
the greatest but you did so that's that
whole thing that what if you know what
if yeah but going back to this so your
story so you're saying Tyrone Woodley I
saw that and ask her when you're coming
up how old are you wrestling with these
guys are you training with these guys
and if yes at what age did that start
when you guys are training together so I
came into Mizzou as an 18 year old as a
freshman Tyron was in his going into his
senior year so I had one year on the
team with Tyron I had two or three two
years with Ben and they were both like
my big brothers and I can tell you right
now Ben askren might be the exact
opposite of me when it comes to
self-image that dude thinks he that dude
thinks that he can do anything and it's
he is the most confident
person I have ever been around in my
entire life yes and I spent so much time
around him and I always felt out of
place and and there was even there was
even moments where I was mad at him or I
would lash out at him or because he was
just like it doesn't make sense to me I
don't understand why you don't believe
in yourself you're beating CP Slater
here by four points and all of a sudden
you gave yourself permission to lose
instead of giving yourself permission to
win and I'm like Ben I don't understand
why I can't win I'm just afraid to I'm
afraid to give myself permission to win
you know whereas a guy like him
I don't know how he developed that but I
sure am studying up hard right now to be
able to instill in my children more like
his thought his thinking than than my
thinking not cocky you're saying pure
confidence you're not saying he was a
little [ __ ] yeah you know he rubbed
people the wrong way but in in UFC I'm
thinking how he was at 20. yeah for sure
and he had he had the fro and he would
he would talk trash and that kind of
stuff and I think you know not to go
back to to quotes but even even just the
the Nelson Mandela quote you know let
your own light shine so you so the
people around you will inadvertently let
their their light shine you know don't
be afraid to be the best because because
other people might feel insecure around
you I think I also I also tried to
operate in such humility that it was a
detriment because I think humility is is
the most beautiful thing it's probably
one of the greatest traits that you can
possibly have but too much humility yeah
it's going to be extremely hard to be
extremely successful because you had you
know limiting beliefs I believe what
it's called I think yeah I think there's
the inner section and kind of that that
fine line between limiting beliefs were
you raised in a church environment were
you raised in a Christian environment or
I was I was raised Catholic
um and then I you know I was actually
the one I got saved really in a
Spirit-filled church when I was 16 and
was one was the one who kind of started
bringing my family to a
non-denominational Christian Church got
it so so sometimes that sometimes that
brings the humility where you you feel a
little bit uncomfortable being Shameless
and promoting and being self-promotion
you know like hey let me tell you here's
what I'm going to be doing because it
kind of comes from a it is one of the
values and principles uh in the
non-denomination to not be doing that
but in your world you're in today that
skill set pays a lot to be you know a
little bit Shameless about promoting
yourself yeah and by the way when you
did it that one time when you won and
you came out and you said hey Connor
yeah you got it it was like boom boom
boom the way you said it but go Max so
when you're when you're wrestling with
the Tyron or what you're wrestling with
Ben uh are are they at this level
superior to yours are like by half are
you guys about the same when you're
going up against them are you are you
developing confidence saying I can hang
with these guys or at that level the
two-year difference between you and Ben
he was Superior to you yeah Ben Ben for
sure and Tyron as well but Tyrone was
more I became somewhat of tyron's uh
tyran's practice dummy because he knew
we were around the same way I was a 157
pounder he's 165 pounder and he knew if
he called me at 4am I'm there if he
calls me at midnight I'm there if he
calls me on the weekend I'm there so I
became that guy because I was once again
the walk-on and this is Tyron Woodley he
was a St Louis Legend he was a you know
a couple time state champion from my
home city as well
um Ben Ben was in a league of his own he
was a couple time Hodge Trophy winner
which is essentially the Heisman of
wrestling
um and but Ben and I traveled then was
yeah Ben Ben was Ben is one of the best
NCAA college wrestlers of all time when
he came out how many game how many fight
win streak did he have I don't remember
what the number one he did well he
didn't lose until he didn't lose until
he came into the see Mazda was his first
loss and he was like 21-0 or that was
the one when mazado knocked him out in
three seconds with the knee of the head
it was six yeah all right
my bad brother seconds over here
uh you know but so Ben was in a league
of his own and those two guys wouldn't
exactly give you much confidence because
I always lost to them and they also had
the big brother they had the big brother
did you ever beat him did you ever beat
him I took Tyron down one time I took
Ben down one time I think maybe in a you
know five years wow so you so so so you
had the edge because you're 167. Tyron
is uh 175. you're going up against
somebody that's got eight pounds on you
which is teaching you how to go up
against a guy a bigger size than you and
a little bit older than your experience
so it's kind of helping you out that's
yeah good positioning for you yeah for
sure and even back back to your point
you know it's the the idea of of the
walk-on what what is the what is the
thread of of success because I talked to
these young guys now I'm training with
I'm trying to have a 22 year old guys
right now I got Scar Tissue older than a
lot of these guys I'm 36 years old you
know and I just say hey man don't think
about you today let's think about let's
think about you 10 years from now you
want to be where I'm at 36 years old
still doing what I'm doing and I made a
career and I'm able to be able to take
care of my family so so with that going
back to college tyron's a you know he's
not even to me in in the sport of of
wrestling mixed martial arts I don't
think you're a true man until 30. that's
that's my true belief that's when I
truly finally felt like a man and maybe
I'm a late bloomer tyron's you know 22
at that time I'm 18 he's got the Big
Brother on me so I wasn't going to beat
him and he was much bigger and I was a
scrawny little freshman
um but I started obviously to hold my
own a little bit more here and there but
it just takes time as well it takes time
in business your first your first
entrepreneurial Adventure compared to
your 50 you're just a different person
you're a galvanized by the fires that
you have put yourself through in
business in relationships and for me it
was obviously physical in the work or in
the in the gym in the strength and
conditioning sessions in the Reps in the
drills and then eventually you know that
that body finally catches up to
hopefully the mindset that you're saying
interesting you're saying 38. it was
about 28 30. yeah so in baseball you
know uh what's his name
he didn't take the contract last year
he's because he wants the 400 million
dollar one but he's 30. so you're gonna
sign the 10-year till 40 I mean pools I
guess came back and cracked the 700
maybe they're going to give him a 10
year 400 million dollar contract good
for him but go going back with you did
you Tyron and uh Ben at all do stand up
or was it purely wrestling uh in college
in college yes yeah I know yeah I think
Tyron so Tyrone was the one who first
started he was training with Eve Edwards
down in down to the American top team
Luigi fioravanti Dean Thomas so Tyron
actually Tyron paved the way for us
because I me and Ben came out of college
I've graduated in May of 2009 fought my
first pro fight in August of 2009 with
almost zero training but Tyron had a
slower Road he had like seven or seven
amateur fights because he just didn't
have the connections because life isn't
about what you know it's who you know
right Tyrone's trying to get in get into
mixed martial arts but has no idea how
to do it finally he meets these guys at
America top 10 he's able to get Pro
fights and
um then he starts his pro career
obviously but
um then so Tyrone was the one who first
started kind of throwing hands and you
know hitting mitts and that kind of
stuff and I started watching them and I
thought man that would be cool and I
started walking through this point
you're not throwing you're not throwing
uh hands you're not no I've never been
in the streets nothing what you've never
been in a street fight until 2020 no
stop it Michael Chandler UFC Legends
you've never been on a street fighter
I'm getting in trouble man I'm not
trying to get in trouble dude how's that
even possible to say something in an
interview where he said hey you know
what happened between you and Dustin
we'll talk about that here in a minute
the whole when Dustin was saying stuff
to you and I said listen I'm not trying
to get into a street fight I'm fighting
in the ring and my wife is next to me
I'm not doing anything but again that's
why like when I hear you speak I sit
there and I say this guy could be a
hedge fund manager he can be an
investment banker like he's a smart
you're a smart guy that you could also
do other things outside of just fighting
so when you're saying you haven't done
that but then it's confusing because you
get hit in the face
[Laughter]
when did you start developing your stand
up and then at what point would you say
I started getting confident that I know
I can really do some damage because you
do damage when you fight and it's not
just wrestling yeah no I uh so I mean I
graduated uh college at 22 I start
through my first kind of punches I mean
I probably maybe this summer before
because Tyrone was still at Mizzou and
training in Columbia Missouri I probably
maybe hit mitts a couple times at 21 or
22 whatever but it was I was solely in
love with and solely focused maniacal
focus on becoming a national champion so
I didn't yes I I kind of knew I want to
do what Big Brother Tyron was going to
do and what Ben was going to do maybe I
want to try that I want to be UFC
champion someday but I was focused on
wrestling so wrestling I knew I had to I
had to put in my 10 000 hours you know
so 21 22 and then um you know I I stuck
around Mizzou and coached for a year and
kind of tried to start training a little
bit I'd go down to Florida come down
here to train with Tyron a little bit
and then come back and coach and then uh
then I moved to Las Vegas and then that
was where I first kind of started my
mind when it comes to Mixed Martial so
so it was all wrestling when it comes to
the hands what did you uh translate with
a boxer or do you just go to just
whatever discipline Jiu Jitsu everybody
else has using their hands and stuff
like that what do you what do you what
do you shift gears do so uh for me I I
looked at it as okay what's the easiest
easiest path to Victory and for me I
knew I was going to be stronger and
tougher than most guys because just the
the microcosm of college wrestling is
something that cannot even be stated to
people who have never been through it
um so I knew I was going to be tougher
than everybody I stood across the cage
from I knew maybe I couldn't Punch Kick
knee elbow maybe more sign tougher what
do you mean just to say that that's like
what do you mean you you know you're
going to be tougher than tougher aside
from them catching me on the button and
me getting knocked out or me getting my
arm broken or me getting caught in some
kind of submission I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna quit because I never quit in
wrestling I'm not going I'm going to be
able to go harder longer and at a higher
Pace with my foot on the gas
better than ever anybody else because of
your confidence is that Mizzou is that
wrestling where's that confidence coming
it's wrestling and it's wrestling and
it's wrestling at Mizzou and I think
Mizzou tiger style wrestling uh was
perfect for me thing you know thank God
I went there because other systems and
other other uh programs might not have
been as great for me but Mizzou
wrestling we had our our list of things
that we were going to do we were going
to be first to the line we were gonna go
hard for seven minutes we're gonna push
people out of bounds we're gonna run
back to the center we're gonna look you
in the eye we were going to break you
mentally before we score more points you
know so that translates over to mixed
martial arts and quite frankly
translates better than any other martial
art or any other background and it's not
because I can pick you up and put you
down and control you it's not because I
have a strong wrestler body it's because
right here I believe that I've been here
you're the same size as me you've got
two arms and two legs you're a man with
a heartbeat you put your pants on one
leg at a time just like me except I
wrestled at Mizzou and I did it for five
years with some of the best guys in the
world and lived that lifestyle and I and
I truly I was around around a lot of
guys who didn't take it as seriously as
me of course didn't they didn't reach
their full potential because they wanted
the college experience I didn't get the
college experience and I would never
trade it for a million years I enjoyed
pouring myself into that wrestling room
at the Hearn Center what do you mean by
you didn't get the college experience as
far as what we do and what we're
supposed to do in college you know go
drink girls yeah wasted do stupid [ __ ]
yeah you know and and you know I mean I
did I have fun of course every now and
then but for for the most part it was
man it was it was wrestling you know how
hard that is to do as a 19 20 year old
kid you're in the midwest you're in
college there's you know nickel beer
nights in Mizzou oh dude I know right
the whole deal and you're just like no I
got rest in practice tomorrow how hard
is that to freaking do when you're 19 20
years old it actually and once again
going back to I there's so many things I
get chills thinking about there's so
many things I look back and I I
sometimes I despise that that young
Michael Channel I'm like why in the heck
didn't you believe in yourself like you
know you're you had to walk onto the
team which mean you had to pay for
college my parents paid for that that
first year and then the second year
until I finally got a scholarship but
why why did you not just believe in
yourself you did everything right why
did you not just believe in yourself but
then
I flipped that on its head and say I'm
so proud of that young man and I'm so
happy that was in my past because I was
filled with so much gratitude as the
walk-on knowing what it was like to be
the lowest guy on the totem pole knowing
what it was like to be overlooked and
I'm not gonna sit here and give you the
you know the Mike Tyson and Floyd
Mayweather thing where they like got you
know wake up at 3am and I'm running in
trash bags no it wasn't that kind of
stuff
sometimes every now and then a little
bit crazy but like you know but but I
was willing to put in more hours I was
willing to do more and then you just it
was it was it was the easiest life ever
you go to class you do your work and you
train every day a lot you know so I just
felt full of gratitude to be able to do
it and to to give anything less than my
best was to sacrifice the gifts that my
my parents had laid out for me and even
just the opportunity for Brian Smith to
say yeah man you can walk on I'm not
gonna look at you for a year I'm not
gonna talk to you for a year you good
luck buddy uh and then yeah I became one
of his favorite wrestlers I tell you
something when you're asking that
question I think it's normal
I I think it's I think Kobe was shy and
Kobe wasn't comfortable around girls and
Kobe was determined about wanting to
make it to the big leagues I think uh
Michael was the same Michael was not
good with girls he was shy he was quiet
he was to himself he wasn't partying and
he got a guy like Dean Smith in his life
and it kind of changed uh you know the
biggest difference is like the way he's
saying
determined at that level to get to the
next level that wasn't me I needed the
Army like I had no clue what I wanted to
do I was all over the place right but
when you're when you're Crystal Clear
early on on what you're trying to solve
for that's the edge that you got for him
to become who he is today and I watch
him like this is a very methodical
disciplined person with values
principles certain things that you're
doing so I'm not surprised with that
part on the confidence side that you
know sometimes that comes later for some
some get it earlier when they talk about
Ben Ben came earlier but going back to
his question on stand up what's tougher
for you was it tougher to learn
wrestling or was it tougher to do and
learn stand up because it's two
different things which one would you say
was tougher for you
um I think it was I think it was tougher
to learn stand up honestly
um you know I think for me I started
obviously at a very I started at a
younger age I started at wrestling at 14
years old I'm not I'm not a man yet I'm
not thinking clearly I'm not I'm still
building confidence I'm still trying to
figure out what my body's how to move my
body at 14 years old I started striking
as a as a seasoned you know young man at
22 years old who had just gone through
the that five-year battle tested of of
Mizzou wrestling so my body my
coordination my speed my quickness my my
strength I didn't do strength strength
and conditioning for my first two years
of of uh of mixed martial arts number
one I couldn't afford it you know to
hire a personal trainer or train with
those guys and number two I already knew
I was going to be bigger faster and
stronger than most of the guys that I
was going to be competing against and I
knew I'm very far behind on striking I'm
very far behind on Jiu Jitsu or Jiu
Jitsu defense
um so I wanted to focus on those things
and that's kind of where by the way Pat
I'd be remiss if I didn't let Vinnie
know we're not talking about stand-up
comments okay as a stand-up comedian
trust me I said stand up a 25 minute
Mark Vinny's like yeah
in my head I was thinking to my head I'm
like so in that because you know
wrestling you once in a while you might
get hit you remember the first time you
felt like the hit in the face you went
oh that's what this is like yeah wow
it's like the first time you get boot
off stage oh my God yeah you want to
throw up you're like whoa and that and
that happens in sparring because you
honestly uh it's hard to explain unless
you've you've been there you but you
don't you don't feel the pain in in
fights you don't feel you don't even
really feel the thud you feel you feel
you know adrenaline is a heck of a drug
man you know and it's just it's coursing
through your veins and you're focused
and you know for me for me I was always
just so offense focused that I think I
was just boom okay keep going boom okay
keep going and uh I go back and watch
yeah but that's how you fight though
like sometimes I watch your fight I'm
like okay you know how you traditionally
when a guy gets hit he gets hit he gets
it and let's just say he's more Jiu
Jitsu guy wrestler he is default to see
you know what this is just too much I'm
a default to Russell let me get his leg
and boom you know but no you're like no
you're stubborn you you you stand up
you're like I'm not gonna go to what I
know I'm better than you and I'm gonna
stand up because I think I'm also a
better fighter than you yeah uh uh in
that and you see that when when the
style of fighting Bellator to UFC okay
we're just fans we watch we're not uh
you know in that world what's the
biggest difference you notice from
Bellator to UFC you had a lot of great
fights in Bellator and then you go into
UFC you've had you know five fights in
UFC and you're already one of the
biggest stars in UFC biggest difference
between Bellator UFC from your eyes
um I think it's a two or two part from
from the promotion side of things it is
it is night and day the UFC has a ton of
employees they are overstaffed in every
single area they have a travel
department they have a PR department
they have a social media department they
have a a health department they have all
of these different departments it is it
is ran like a finely tuned Fortune 500
company Bellator was awesome and I love
the people it just it was understaffed
and there wasn't it it wasn't a finely
tuned machine and then from the
promotional side of things
people just care so much more about the
UFC they've been around for so much
longer they started in 1993.
um you know they are they are the
worldwide leader in mixed martial arts
by a long shot nobody is even coming
close to scratching the surface of what
the UFC does when people think about
fighting they think about the UFC first
and then yeah and then so I noticed that
you know I noticed you know I just like
in college wrestling I I always thought
I was the hardest worker in the room and
now in in mixed martial arts even when
even when I'm training with these guys
in the UFC I was training harder than
them than them longer than them being
more disciplined with my diet than them
being more disciplined with my weight
cut my lifestyle than them yet they were
getting all of the all of the platform
all of the cameras all of the eyeballs
all of the followers all of the
everything and I was the guy who was
somewhat out you know outside of the UFC
as a world-class talent but wasn't
getting the opportunity to be looked at
that because I wasn't fighting the best
guys in the world on the biggest
promotion and now you just gotta you
just gotta work long long and hard and
keep a good reputation until that
reputation stays up there and then all
of a sudden the platform intersects at
the exact right time and my platform is
high and or the platform is high and the
reputation was high
and it worked out well I I once the
sports are now is like is it the NFL to
like arena league XFL you know I don't I
was it NBA versus College what's the the
bigger Sports not bigger sports but yeah
I mean I guess what is yeah something
something like that I mean any any and
that's thing I I it's hard for me to
talk about too because I I love being an
employee of the UFC I love being a part
of the UFC I have loved these last two
years but I do love those people at
Bellator I love my path once again just
like I talked about I'm I'm happy that I
was that small guy from the small town
and it's kind of your narrative yeah
with the walk-on yes and then and then
I'm happy that I started in Bellator and
I came over at the exact right time with
the exact right question for you so
what's the biggest uh difference between
Steve uh uh how do you say his last name
is it Coker Steve Coker
I'm sorry Scott Coker and Dana White
what's the difference between the two of
them
um I think um
it's uh I mean Dana's Dana's just Dana's
a on a different level when it comes to
the celebrity you know like Dana's a
huge huge name Dana is is the when he
speaks people listen when he speaks it
is it is mixed martial arts that's what
people you know take any because he's
been doing it doing it for so much
longer
um you know Dana's a little bit more
Brash um Scott's a little bit more a
little bit more reserved so there's pros
and cons to both of those you know from
uh from a media and PR perspective I'm
sure you could talk to the UFC about
that but
um you know
um but I I will say I think
I think Scott Coker does take growing
Bellator seriously but not as serious as
Dana I think Dana eats sleeps and
breatheses it it is his identity it is
his lifestyle it is him the UFC is Dana
White and Dana White is the UFC and
that's a beautiful thing I got a crazy
uh question for you and crazy idea
I don't even have this in my thing I'm
just thinking about it so I'm looking at
what bellator's Top Line was right now
okay it's not a big number 80 million
100 million on what they're doing per
year I mean obviously UFC is doing a lot
more you know what would be crazy
it would be very crazy you know how Dana
says look you want to do this go start
your league see how hard it is and he's
right it's very very hard it's very very
hard
imagine if a person with the personality
of Dana goes and buys Bellator and
promotes Bellator and puts the you know
marketing eyeballs and I know a couple
guys that are big trolls that are very
loud if some of them were to buy it it
would be a very interesting competition
between two leagues to then obviously
Dana's got a lead by a mile and a half
it's not even close yeah but if you were
to get somebody with a big personality
to get Bellator who does the eyeballs
and the marketing
I mean you look I mean how many how many
Dana whites are out there Vince McMahon
is one yeah Dana White's one who else
you put at that level uh uh I don't know
if Don King may be at his Peak back in
the days let's just say you put it down
you know uh uh I don't know who else you
put in that level promoting promoter
goes listen to be that you have to can
you imagine like you're the boss of
badass you know mother I mean you're the
boss of people that on any given day
camp whoop
99.999999 of people's Tales anywhere in
the street fight right these guys are
people so so then imagine managing
leading negotiating saying No this is
the way or the highway you don't do this
I'm okay I'm doing that's not that's not
everybody's job only a few people can do
that job right yeah and you take
wrestling versus you know UFC wrestling
gets big egos but they don't know how to
fight like UFC does UFC is Big Egos and
they know how to fight and you're
leading them and you're set getting it
straight there's not too many Dana
whites but if some people claim they can
really do it better than UFC there's a
Bellator you can go by and do something
with that yeah no and it's uh I mean
yeah Dana's just he he wants to be he
wants to be bigger than the NFL he wants
to be bigger than the MLB you know he's
in he's you know decades behind
obviously those guys those what NFL
started and what he wants to be big MLB
yeah yeah he wants to be I mean 50
people he hasn't told me that but yeah
that's that's kind of you you feel it
that's it and that's and that's the kind
of that's just the kind of mentality
that that you you want in your your boss
you know like that's that's what I
resonate with and that's in my meeting
with my first phone call with him I just
you know I said hey I want to be a good
thing for your organization I promise
you you have never signed a guy that is
more equally yoked with you and told him
that yes and he hung up on me
what do you mean he hung up on me and
called Hunter Campbell yeah who is who
is his who is his right hand man yeah
you know so then he called me back and
then you know a couple days later we you
know got a
what was that moment where he was just
like you know what I'm I'm shifting
gears and I'm I'm done I'm out was it a
fight was it a moment was like a a
mental thing was it a relationship what
was your like I'm out it was definitely
not relationship the relationship was
always great I loved Scott Coker and I
loved Rich Chu and Mike kogan all the
all those guys I would and that's just
always been me I
I'm in this position because I tried to
always think about making myself an
indispensable asset to my current
promotion so then if I ever did want to
go somewhere else it's chill it it's
it's chill as as well as I have a higher
value to then be taken somewhere else
which worked out you know well and now
I've still got the same mentality with
the UFC I want to be I want to be the
UFC's favorite fighter the easiest one
to work with the most entertaining the
one who brings the eyeballs the one
who's the easiest to work with the one
who treats the janitor at the ufcpi the
same way that I would treat Hunter
Campbell or Dana White because that
stuff trinkles up the word question the
word gets up when you have 170 something
employees the way that you treated that
person is going to get to their higher
up in there and it's well it's it's just
being a nice person too but you say that
but you say that yeah and and you think
it's normal but it's not when you get
the camera the like you know the you
know all the Limelight everything it's
it's it's not uh you know it's very when
somebody makes a first million all of a
sudden it comes too quickly most people
don't know how to handle that yeah and
when somebody gets a lot of Limelight
most people don't know how to handle
that you know it's a it's a tough thing
but for you to be able to do that that's
great the the person I was thinking
about to buy Bellator is a guy named I
don't know if you've heard of this guy
what's the guy's name I won't say his
name is Jake last name is
that his name
didn't something just come out about
Jake Paul is talking about you or MMA
promotions he said something I heard
something he said he's about to announce
something that's right yeah something
that he was teasing about fighting in
the MMA I was at one point I was gonna
ask you about two fights what I'm saying
is
his move to MMA says he's working with a
big Organization for possession
but this is what I'm saying forget about
the debut this is my my thing this
you're putting 40 million here 10
million 20 million Jay can go to an
investment banker raise 200 million
dollars if these guys are doing 100
million a year say their uh profit
margins 20 they're making 20 say it's 10
times 200 million say you have to buy
for 300 million raise 300 million
dollars go buy these guys be the Dana
you can do the fight and do that and
then promote I mean he's and by the way
then Dana can say I told you it's hard I
told you this [ __ ] is hard this ain't
easy right because they've had they've
been at each other's well Jake's been a
Dana's throat you know for the whole the
whole fighter pay thing and yeah all of
that stuff and why do you not think he
has uh some some weight there to to
carry with his uh you know essentially
calling him out you don't think he has
some credibility there as far as the
calling him out for everything he's
talking about with the fighter fight
insurance and just you know I think I'm
fighting I mean I think
if if guys were unhappy with the way
that they were getting paid you'd see
more guys because it's you know
everybody's contract ends and the UFC
does not hold you hostage they say go
wherever you want to go everybody stays
in the UFC yeah because where else is
the other option Bellator there is a
great options I Bellator is a great
organization pfl is a is a great
organization and they are building
there's a numerous other organizations
out there but you can't at at one at one
time say these guys don't pay me enough
and then you stick around you sign
another six fight deal you sign another
eight fight deal another four or five
deal so you know I think just going
going back to that walk-on mentality it
all goes back to the the Gratitude as
well I feel grateful to be a part of the
UFC and I get called a boot licker and I
get called a brown noser and that's fine
I don't care I am I am I am who I am and
that's how I've always conducted it and
my career is working out pretty you're a
flat carrier it's a but that's that's
called Flat carrier mentality it's you
carry the flag for whatever team you
represent like for example you know
Antonio Brown okay what an incredible
Talent right you know when you watch
this guy play just an incredible Talent
what he was doing it's it's crazy most
people probably forgot this case to play
for Pittsburgh right he was a yes the
best receiver of the league
people are thinking it's you know Brady
no this guy was at Pittsburgh forget
Raiders forget it yeah he was at
Pittsburgh
what may be the best coach outside of
you know one of them yeah Tomlin yeah
yeah tomlin's a a beast of a guy Man how
he but you know Brown he's doing what
he's doing he's like well I look at this
and then he posts a picture with him and
uh you know Brady's wife two days ago
and you're like what like what yeah like
he was trying to but but the point is
but the point is the point and then he
makes a video with uh the coach and he
puts it publicly while he's talking to
the coach of the Raiders you know who
I'm talking about the coach John Gruden
John Gruden that's not flag carrier men
some people think like that's like
that's what you need to be what
organization wants to have person like
that on their team that's that big of a
distraction well there's a big
difference between us and item soon he's
a person that only cares about himself
that's clear versus a US mentality
clearly what you're talking about UFC is
you call me a brown noser a boot licker
but I'm part of an organization or a
team that I care about your mentality
exactly and I'm being off authentic to
who I am yeah I've always been that way
and and even now there there is nothing
that will ever benefit me from ever you
know pressing Bellator trashing Bellator
and be well truthfully it is honest I do
think they're they're all all great and
it's still a great organization do I am
I happy that I went to the USC
absolutely but that doesn't mean that I
want to bash anybody else you know some
people call it class yeah that's what it
is
I could tell your parents at a freaking
amazing job I could tell your spiritual
like you know you say you're going to
church and stuff I cuss like a sailor it
hasn't cussed one time no interviews no
nothing I respect for you this is the
picture that Antonio Brown posted you're
saying posted this place can you scroll
down this is this an Instagram post yeah
he posted this no say yeah it's on TMZ
because mind you you know because Tom
Brady and his wife they just TMZ are
like they're reporting that yeah they're
hired divorce lawyers so that's not
gonna lie but you know that's between
them they're going through what they're
going through to do something like this
while that announcement is being made
and the way Brady handled you yeah when
you left and he said look you know it
was a great time running with this guy I
think we have to pay a little bit more
attention to people that are going
through challenging time I wish him
nothing but the best and he still gave
him respect that when you do this this
is you know I I posted this pic yeah
posted that on Instagram he posted on
Instagram and then he exposed himself in
a pool in uh in Mexico or somewhere he's
he's off the charts right now anyways I
don't want to talk about Antonio Brown
I'm just making I'm going to you with
this I'm not making a point here just
just going back to what you said too I
mean there's you know that's what the
UFC and Bellator and all of these guys
have to to deal with I mean at some
point you talk about athletes and you
then you talk about guys who are not
just athletes but they're also fighters
I mean it's not easy to not easy to
handle all of that no manage all of that
and then you're doing however many
dozens and dozens I think the UFC is
probably gonna do 50 something shows
this year it's crazy you know and 13 or
14 pay-per-views and these are huge huge
I mean did you see what happened a
couple weeks ago with the Diaz
Diaz hamzat Ferguson Ferguson Holland
first time ever we're not the we're not
doing the press conference because of
what I said on the back they shuffled
the whole card around within 24 hours of
of the car with the weight in situation
yeah you know it was a very very no
listen I mean to me uh uh uh when covet
happened you know and everything was
going on this guy is the top
Commissioner of all sports is Dana White
period
Manfred is at the bottom you know you
look at Adam Silver's probably number
three or number four you know number two
is probably gonna register Roger Goodell
even though he doesn't but there is
nobody at this guy's level Dana is in a
league of his own if everybody's number
two Dana's number one by mile then it
comes everybody else people think it's
an easy job to do what he does by the
way did you see what he looked like
recently with his uh can you post a
picture of a he's ripped when you saw
that picture what did you think yeah no
it's it was I was pumped up
you know well not only the picture but
you're also like well it's kind of cool
that you're you know you have you have
that come to Jesus moment where you're
like okay I got 10 years to live if I
don't look at this guy figuring some
stuff out you know and I mean I mean
yeah he's had health issues he's had you
know all kinds of stuff that he probably
doesn't even make public but he's had
some public health issues because you
know as you would know running any kind
of company it's a 24-hour Biz 24-hour
job and you know he's done a very good
job of of overstaffing his his the
organization and one of the greatest I
think one of the greatest leadership
moments that he will ever have was on
that Diaz card when that the fight broke
out at that press conference he not once
said I'm dealing with a bunch of
lunatics I'm dealing with a bunch of
crazy Fighters hop hopped up on on
adrenaline and this and that he never
said one bad thing about the fighters he
said next time we'll be more prepared we
will have more staff we we're we usually
are overstepped here we usually have
more security guards we more usually
have more security detail he said it no
less than 10 times in that interview and
I almost made a post about it but I
don't want to be called a brown liquor
brown nose or boot licker you know too
much but you know it's it was it was a
very pivotal moment I think when he when
we will look back at his career when he
when that happened and he did not take
he only took the blame and not just the
UFC he took the blame and that's why he
is who he is doesn't show hurt he does
what he does and people respect them but
to look like this right now yeah and
look at those abs
53 54 is where he's at so so go going
back to uh going back to you know the
the fight that you got coming up right
now between you and um Dustin uh it's
interesting because you know Dustin you
know 28 fights in UFC you've had five
right and you've come in and you fought
everybody you know you came in you know
Dan hooker you have to fight you know uh
Dustin goes 25 minutes with him you go
two and a half minutes with them okay so
that's a comparison that we got to make
in the market then you go with Charles
uh I think Charles comes after that
right Charles comes after that you
almost won that one I mean it was like
this right uh then you're going with you
know Justin and that's fight of the
night fight of the Year everyone's gone
the fight of the year it was insane of a
fight it's one of those fights that
you'll watch regularly because it
doesn't get old when you watch that
fight the kicks the left leg the story
you're kicking he's kicking you're
kicking he's Kings like nobody wants to
stop kicking it was a it was like a two
minute thing you're just going like this
is insane with these guys for like six
weeks
[Music]
seriously don't throw kicks kids they
hurt no I don't know if you've seen this
with these kids because he's known
Justin's known that he's gonna he's
Relentless about throwing these kicks
again it's constant yeah but he's also
going back and forth back and forth
anyways then you have your you know last
the last fight you have with the uh Tony
you know knockout of the year do you
mean the kicker around the world yeah
man it's just that was a slow motion of
his face yeah I mean everyone's seen
that one that took place and by the way
classic you know the way it was spoken
in announced coming up to Dustin so
this this me meet up with Dustin you
know we've heard and we've seen
everything between you know what's been
said and what he said and what you said
and Ariel is asking you about him and
I'm not thinking about fighting him
because at the time he was talking about
retirement and you know and you said
you've never used those words retirement
I'm not thinking about retirement he was
so that's why I was thinking about
fighting somebody else you know and you
know for for him to approach you at a
fight and then you know Cormier puts the
two of you guys down it was a great
conversation a full 14-minute
conversation was classic because uh he's
trying to steer it apart and you can
tell Dustin was upset and you're trying
to just stay poised and calm but he's
saying what he's saying to you and you
know shots are being fired and then now
some people are saying well these guys
are hugging they're friends what is it
is it act do they hate each other do
they want is this going to be a real
fight or are we going to see like uh too
friendly of a fight so today with you
know what the market has seen and what's
really going on where are you at with
this fight coming up it's the you know a
fight everyone's looking forward to what
are you thinking about with is it really
a fight that there's going to be
animosity to fight or is it just two
professionals getting in the ring to
fight I think the overarching theme is
is it's two professionals getting in
getting in there to fight
um you know I think you know you talk
about the the hug like that was that was
pre that was pre-beef you know that was
me and me and Dustin sat there for an
hour before weigh-ins just kind of
talking about everything he's trying my
groove life ring on because he was
wearing a silicone ring I'm like hey
these are the best but I'll send you
some blah blah blah we're talking about
our kids we're talking about our wives
we're talking about you know what we do
um and there was a lot of mutual respect
and then right after that fight that was
when he the the illustrious hey if they
want me to fight Chandler I'd rather
just go sell hot sauce so then there was
kind of the you know the just pushing me
aside so I'm like okay wait a second
okay I thought we were cool
and I didn't you know take that into I
don't know I didn't didn't really take
it too personally
um because at that point I knew I
probably wasn't going to fight Dustin
next or maybe I was who knew at that at
that point in time and then you know
since then I have done some interviews
where I'm like you know I'm I'm kind of
I've taken this I've had debut of the
year in 2021 I had knockout of the year
or the year uh fight of the year in 2021
I might have knockout of the year in
2022 you know so I'm continuing to rise
and rise and rise and Dustin was talking
about going to 170 talking about
fighting Diaz which we all know what
that means it's not exactly like you're
trying to stay on the trajectory to win
the title he did say retirement so I did
take the Liberty to maybe maybe it was a
little bit disrespectful to say I'm not
even thinking about Dustin and there was
one moment where I actually did forget
Dustin's name because I think I had
pushed his name out of my my top five of
who I would fight because I thought he
was moving up to 170 and whatnot so
maybe it was a little bit subconscious
on accident
and he took you know he took a fence to
that so they're then you know the the
video of us at the the fight obviously
he he wanted to say his piece which I
respect you know he doesn't need to
tweet me you know even though he has
tweeted me and then I roasted him with
an awesome Tweet back which he even said
Chandler roasted me because I'm in at
the end yeah is that the one you're
talking about no it was actually it was
it was actually no it was willing to get
into it it was great he called me
Michael Chandler you know so I don't
have a chin right and then and I said
and I said speaking of speaking of chins
Michael Johnson fights tonight the last
time Dustin Poirier fought Michael
Johnson was this date in Hidalgo Texas
and he knocked out Dustin Poirier you
know like and I used hashtag chin
history but then he came back with I
don't even know what to say that's
awesome you know got you so there was
even that kind of mutual that's cool
that's the kind of stuff that's how I
would respond as well if he did that to
me I'd be like okay what do I say here
like let him keep going okay
so there's there's that you know I think
there's a mutual respect I think him and
I are very similar in a lot of ways I
think our values are are very similar I
think we fight for our families we fight
for our Legacy and we we you know we
take the sport you can actually stand up
with this guy
no I've been known to do some stands
yeah I mean I think I can knock him out
I think he can knock me out I think so I
think we both have the confidence there
on the on the on the feet
um I think my wrestling is better I
think my grappling is better honestly I
think I I always go in there with the
game plan of mixing up and keeping them
guessing yeah I haven't done a great job
of that in the UFC thus far
um but it's bowed me well with the the
fans in my platform you know you know
one thing from Connor that you know when
he was a first time he fought Diaz and I
don't know if you remember the first
fight that of course I'm sure you've
seen the fight but the first time he
fought Diaz he hit him and he went to
him yeah he hit him and he went to him
he hit him and he went to him right he's
trying to say I'm gonna beat you at your
game as well you know kind of like
that's what I'm going to be doing now
you know people thought Francis and last
fight he was just going to do stand up
he didn't he beat him and ground as well
which was kind of like damn yeah nobody
expected him to do this so Connor lost
the first fight
was supposed to win the first fight
right he lost the first fight second
fight I don't know if you first time he
knocks he had some Nate drops yeah and
uh oh you know he's not going to him
yeah and then you hear Joe and
everyone's like oh he's not going to him
he's asking him stand up then he stands
up again happens he did it three times
to him yep he never went to him which
you know props to him for having that uh
control during that moment to know hey
this is not what I should do because
that guy's better than me in this area
yeah let's just say you're fighting
Dustin and all of a sudden you're like
okay this guy packs a punch you know and
you pack a punch both of you guys pack a
punch but you know do you think the the
strategy and you don't have to tell me
anything I'm you know again on what I'm
saying with this part but I'm only
asking this because for me if you know
khabib would show he can hang
you know and then but all of a sudden
khabib would go and say nah man this is
not my fight I'm gonna beat you at my
fight how hard is it to set aside your
own Spirit of competition and fire to
say dude I know if I wrestle you I'm
gonna beat you but I want to beat you at
your fight to say I kind of need this
victory for me to be on a two win streak
three one streak four win streak then
I'm gonna get through Charles back again
let's just say Charles doesn't have the
title by that time it's going to be
another person I'm still going to get
that championship fight then I'm gonna
get the big pay there let's just say
Conor comes back because Dana wants the
two of you guys to fight
do you do you are you going to take a
khabibra out are you going to take the
entertainment route no I'm definitely
taking the win route okay I'm taking
that I will I will obviously every every
fight starts on the feet yeah um so
we'll start on the feed obviously you
know if if the you know a lot of times
too you there's that fine line between
fight or flight and being able to
actually make decisions on the Fly uh or
maybe you're just flowing and you make a
decision and all of a sudden you take a
guy down you didn't even try to shoot it
just happened your body shot you grabbed
a leg you picked them up and put them
down you know there's it's such a it's
such an interesting
mindset when you're actually in there
because people say it all the time why
did you do this or why did you do that
and I'm like I really didn't have
control over it you know maybe maybe I
should have done a little bit more work
uh at visualization maybe I should have
done a little bit more work in my
training of of of use doing more dry
runs and more situationals and more
opportunities to make sure I make the
right decisions but a lot of times
you're not really a hundred percent in
control as much as the the media and the
fans and the onlookers think that you
are but truthfully yes there will be a
game plan and that game plan will be
mixing it out and about you know we're
fans you know no it's good no I I
appreciate it because that's a good it's
a good it's a very good question because
yeah you have to I've done a very good
job I think thus far of creating a brand
of Michael Chandler's in a very exciting
fighter but no you you're the most no no
well thank you and listen cause look I'm
not going to tell you he's not exciting
I'm not going to tell you Alexander you
know uh Israel no no no no no what's his
name alcohol
right
he's freaking but to me you're the most
exciting fighter period that's my
opinion you know you're the most
exciting fighter when you when you fight
I can't sit down I have to stand up when
I watch new fights I can't sit down
watch your fight I gotta come watch a
fight with you
what is it about I love the backflips no
no no what is it during the fight that
excites you so much for example like you
know you uh I don't want to say this
because it's your friend oh God Tyron
you know he he was coming up in like
four times and then all of a sudden he
started like you know playing it too
safe and even Dana got at one point it
was like what is this guy doing we got
to sell tickets here you know this is
not just about the points and scoring
the points we need a little bit of both
like get in there so he got a little too
much to be too careful to get the
Victory and that's not good you saw the
other day Israel had a fight people were
born I don't know if you remember the
Israel fight where they were born like
what was that listen I'm scoring the
points and then the two girls that
fought the worst fighters ever that was
on that was on my card I think do you do
I think so which actually works out
really well I've been very fortunate to
have some somewhat boring fights
did you watch that fight did you
actually watch that fight or you didn't
get it because it's your card so I don't
know if you watched it no usually that
was right after me and I I went and did
probably 20 30 minutes it was it was the
most important
fight each other one time that's very
weird right so so you have to sell
tickets so as a Dana White like you you
want guys like you like Conor like you
know you're not gonna do what Connor
does so you know the difference between
you and Connor is Conor's gonna do laps
around you and talking smack right and
not just you anybody including
Mayweather like yeah oh my God Conor is
a top five smack talker in the world
today I don't know who I put ahead of
him maybe you got him you got Trump you
got Jake you got some of these guys that
are fantastic Elon Musk is a troll some
of these guys Connor's on another level
no no he's on a whole different level
when he does it so you're like you just
yeah I watch the the press conference
with Mayweather more than I watch the
fight yeah and I watched the press
conference more times than I watched the
fight one time I watched the conference
that was fun so so but but the but the
part where I'm going with this is
you know there's the balance of the
eyeballs and then there is the journey
to go get the championship to get that
part uh man it's a it's it's got to be
and then you know when you're talking
when you're fighting getting hit you
don't know if you're getting hit and all
that other stuff and one of the fights
that you had you know when you're
fighting like because you'll go all out
with everybody you're not gonna stop but
you're saying what is the most exciting
part from the first second to the last
second he's moving yeah there is no like
uh you know there is no all gas no
breaks no he's fighting from beginning
to the end he's fighting and it's it's
hard it's hard to see those kinds of
fights yes he brings it it's not always
the it's not always the best idea it's
not always the easiest path to Victory I
think I think there was times where I
would I thought man I wish I would have
been a little bit more patient here
because I mean there is it is I mean I I
when I fought in Bellator I fought I
don't know how many title fights but I
although they were all scheduled for 25
minutes and 25 minutes inside of the
cage is a long time 15 minutes is a long
time but in that 15 minutes there's
moments where you can take rests rest
there's moments where you can take your
foot off the gas I've never found those
I'm always I'm always going forward I'm
always you know getting in the fight
because I always I I fought exactly how
I wrestled I put my toe on the line the
referee blew the whistle and I put my
hands on you and I'm pushing you and I'm
pulling you and I am attacking for seven
minutes straight and I just have kept
that mentality my entire career and you
know it's worked out it doesn't always
work out but I mean all of my fights
have always been like that all of my
fights in Bellator Win Lose or Draw
they've always been you know pretty
pretty is it to say that's your style
like genuine bracelet so from uh from a
competitor standpoint they're like all
right I'm fighting Michael you know that
he's gonna do this oh he's coming at you
so how does that put you you know you
know sort of like they know what you're
gonna do already because that's your
style he's attack attack attack all
right so if you're using who Dustin he
is as well yeah he's also that way so
that's why this is a very interesting
matchup but you know it's an interesting
matchup but if it goes to the you know
ground I mean it's it's gonna be so I
had to do this I've seen you do some
stuff with bodies when your body's
slamming dropping your music oh my God
like I was watching the Bellator once
you're talking about you're just like if
I had to describe your fighting it's
like a wild like a gorilla just jumping
on your ass like I forgot which fight it
was Bellator and you were it was a ball
dude and you did it was a stand-up
Guillotine the guy's head turned that
color right I thought was going to pop
off it was a standard standing
Guillotine and then he just dropped like
you just don't let them breathe which is
that to go forward and just don't stop
bro don't let them breathe when you
attack you got it you got to take the
opportunity you gotta attack and you
hold it until that's right off Pat you
remember uh we you interviewed Dustin
Poirier 13 months ago at the Vault yeah
so uh it was right on the heels of the
McGregor yeah which is crazy he was the
biggest name in UFC at that point you
beat McGregor I mean yeah but do you
remember what you asked him about how he
prepares for a fight and then he puts
the date on the calendar
and he circles uh you know what he can
control and then outside of the calendar
outside of the circle
uh was everything else yep the media the
noise the [ __ ] talking the you know
you're never gonna be this whatever it
was very impressive you remember this uh
it was it was something that stuck with
me about him it's like you can control
what's in this circle outside of that
nothing you can do what's your
preparation look like what's your
mindset look like coming into a fight
um you know I uh I can't say that I have
any kind of chart like that
um but I do I think for me I've just
been I've been training for for so long
I do every training camp is is different
but every training camp is very much the
same you know we train two or three
times a day
five six days a week right now I've made
it I made it I made a choice when I came
down here and started training in
Florida my family lives in Nashville or
we all live in Nashville but I come here
for eight nine ten weeks at a time I was
gonna fly home every every Friday and I
was gonna fly back every Sunday and if
my if my career if it was a detriment to
my career I was willing to make that
choice and that sacrifice and it's
worked out fine so
Monday through Thursday I trained twice
uh twice a day between practices I
honestly try to fill my time up with
with things you know even when I was
scheduling this you know I was like Hey
usually usually I'm between two and one
and five pm
usually works out well for me today
worked out well because I lifted it two
trained at 10 lifted it two and then we
have this evening
um so I just try to spend a lot of time
I always do my morning routine of you
know prayer visualization reading a
devotional maybe listening to some music
or even something on YouTube that's kind
of getting me pumped up
um not really pumped up but more just
edified built up
um because yeah the this this TR these
training camps will beat you down to
your knees if you let it and you have to
you have to pull away sometimes you have
to fill up your cup thank God you know
for me going home on the weekends I'll
take two days off sometimes and just be
with my family that fills up my cup and
then I can just go grind the you know
grind the grindstone for Monday through
Friday again and so it sounds like
you're a major system guy yeah I mean
right yeah and I like to I like to fill
up you know right right now I'm really
trying to fill Things fill my day up
with things or else you just sit around
you think about the fight and you might
you might think well that sounds good
you gotta think about the fight as much
and it's like no not really because I
can one of the most important things I
think in business relationships any
Endeavor in sport is being able to trust
yourself can you trust yourself I know
without a shadow of a doubt when that
cage door closes and that referee says
are you ready or you're ready go I can
trust myself to go out there and do do
it and do what I need to do so so
everything else going back to you the
the chart is is just noise you know if I
sit there for three hours and do I need
to you know watch mindless Netflix okay
maybe you know maybe I or maybe I do
watch film maybe I do watch some film
with my coach but for the most part I
compartmentalize that two hours in the
morning that two hours in the evening
maybe a little bit of visualization or
today I had Bodywork an hour long
massage
to build the body that that trust you
talk about which is very powerful I mean
when he said that I'm like okay that
that doesn't sound like the Michael from
10 years ago it sounded like you didn't
trust yourself or you didn't trust your
mindset right now I trusted myself to to
self-sabotage myself more than I trusted
myself to am I always gonna win do I
trust myself to win no because this is
the sport of mixed martial arts I'm
fighting a another world-class man and
four ounce gloves and anything can
happen but do I trust myself to know
that from the beginning of training camp
to the end of training camp did I leave
no stone unturned in my preparation did
I do every single thing right that I
needed to do and once you have that
you can go out you can go out there and
compete and and TR and train and and go
when those lights turn on you can just
trust yourself to you know be up to the
will of whatever is going to happen that
night uh Mike the when you have had all
these fights you've had I asked Dustin
who's the hardest puncher that he went
with he said Connor and then he said the
toughest opponent he said khabib is who
he said when we were talking
who have you faced that you would say
was the toughest best punch and as well
as the best ground Grappler
um
it's uh I mean from a from a striking
just just an absolute dog standpoint it
was it was Justin gaichi or even Eddie
Alvarez or Eddie Alvarez I mean we
fought last time we fought was like 2013
or 14 or something like that yeah
um but the
I think the toughest and hardest hardest
fight uh from a strategic standpoint
from a
from a ever it seemed like everything
you tried to do you couldn't hurt the
guy was a guy Benson Henderson wow
Benson Henderson former UFC champion
came over to Bellator I fought him twice
I passed out in the between the fourth
and fifth round the first time I fought
him that was the big suplex that
happened and I beat the tar out of him
for two three rounds the guy didn't have
a red mark he didn't have a scrape he
didn't I remember and I'm looking at him
and he just like throwing his big hair
up and I'm just like dude are you a
robot so I mean there's there's nothing
worse than that that's actually I've had
a I've you know
I I've had gone back and looked at you
know watched that fight and just thought
man I hit him with everything but the
kitchen sink and and the guy just
flipped his hair back and looked like he
you know he did a very he had a very
very good poker face and even though you
knew he had a poker face that poker face
still got to you and you're just like ah
going at him and and he was good on the
ground he was Gumby on the ground I
slammed him on his head you know with
the probably one of the greatest
suplexes in mixed martial arts history
and he gets up like dude that hair was
cushioned but he but he wasn't he wasn't
kind of a Savage offensive like gaichi
was where he's gonna hit you with leg
kicks he's gonna hit you with knees he's
gonna throw a thousand punches he wasn't
same thing with Eddie Alvarez same thing
with even you know Charles Oliveira
who's becoming more and more offensive
with his Muay Thai
um
so yeah Benson Henderson was the most
durable toughest guy that I ever fought
and then obviously the hardest puncher
would be I think just engaging
just engage Justin gay guy he's a
scrapper bro we're gonna fight again we
will we will fight again so you're gonna
fight Charles again
I beat Dustin November 12th and then I
fight I think Charles is going to beat
Islam and I I fight Charles Yeah March
or April next year and I win the title
and I put it right here how the hell is
Charleston Underdog I don't I don't I
don't understand it and I and I've and
I've answered this question now three or
four times and I always get Flack for it
because everybody thinks I'm hating on
Islam I'm not necessarily hating on
Islam Islam Islam is about as impressive
as you can possibly be and look and get
a title shot without ever having fought
somebody inside the top five
um so I don't understand I think it's uh
I think it's maybe the dagestani khabib
connection Mystique of him you know
being khabib's you know brother ish you
know so that's the guy that told you to
shut up and stay in your lane uh
probably I mean they add I mean people
probably I don't remember that probably
Islam yeah uh so so my God I got a
question so uh like as a stand-up
comedian I'd go on stage like it really
it doesn't happen now but you know what
happens from time to time when you're
just not the crowd and you it just
doesn't connect you say one word you're
off the rails and it's it's a log I mean
like it that stays with a comedian bro
it's depressing a lot of them do crazy
stuff they drink they do drugs some of
them which I know they commit suicide
what how do you and it takes us a while
to get back until I do another dope set
then I'm kind of getting back but that
thing still sits on my mind when it
comes to taking a loss how do you how do
you deal with a loss and how do you not
let it affect you for how long how long
until it's in your head Mikey and then
you're just like I'm done you move
forward does it linger to your next
fight like how do you how do you deal
with that that's actually a really
really awesome question because the the
best part about mixed martial arts is
the lifestyle that we get to live where
we only fight two to three times a year
maybe four times a year every now and
again now and again and if you're and if
you built a great career and you and you
have great fight person and you have
good sponsors and you're able to make a
great living you don't want to be in
training Camp the whole year you want to
have some down time
but on the flip side of that that very
positive is also a very big negative
because we talk about the sport of
wrestling or stand-up comedy you might
do two shows in a row and you might do a
show of five weeks in a row or five you
know so you take an L one night and
people are booing you or they're
throwing whether you throw tomatoes yeah
whatever yeah I've seen people throw
batteries yeah
you feel like hey this isn't working out
I am a loser right 100 but then you get
an opportunity very soon to get back on
stage and right that wrong wrestling was
the same thing if I lost a dual meet on
Wednesday we're gonna wrestle again on
Saturday I can get back in the win con
when I can move forward so the problem
or the the hardest part about mixed
martial arts is when you do take a loss
not only are you most likely in pain
maybe you got some stitches maybe you
got some swelling maybe you're limping
around you know
you then you then you see all the media
and then you see people's you know
people's reaction and that kind of stuff
and you try not to let it get to you and
you don't get the opportunity to right
that wrong for three four five six one
and eight months so and and I and I
actually I actually uh had a had a a
part of my story I went 688 days without
winning a fight wow I was the Bellator
Champion I lost to Eddie Alvarez I lost
I lost my first fight and in that moment
that small guy from the small town for
who was taught to do small things who I
thought I had duct taped to the basement
of my mind yeah yeah crept back in and
said I told you you were in a monster I
told you you weren't good I told you
everything that they said about you was
Far false everything that you believed
about yourself was false and that loss
turned into another loss and then
another loss and I lost three three
fights in a row and I had to do a lot of
work to get back to believing in myself
and believing that I was created and
destined for great things so so the the
great thing thing about this mixed
martial arts life is we do get time off
between fights but it's you know when
you take a loss
you know there's sometimes you take a
you get an awesome win like my Tony
Ferguson fight I was on top of the world
like man I'm kind of kind of ready to
get back get kind of ready to get back
in there I would love to like keep this
momentum going get the kid toward the
title shot
um and then there's some wins where
you're like okay I'm gonna rest on these
coattails for just a second let me let
me come out because you got to remember
you're also talking to somewhat of a
robot right now I'm in training camp and
I gotta do all these things that I have
to do and and you wouldn't get the same
me
luckily I'm able to compartmentalize it
when I'm able to have an awesome
platform like this and thank you for
giving me this but I am somewhat of a
robot and you want to pull yourself away
from that my son doesn't my sons don't
want to you know my son's hap doesn't
want to play in the backyard with a
robot when I go home this weekend I'm
gonna be a little bit different daddy
than I normally am because I'm in
training camp and I'm focused and I try
to compartmentalize it and I don't do a
great job of it at that same time same
thing with my wife same thing with my
new baby Ace
um
so congratulations Mike and this is your
second this is your second kit that you
adopted bro God bless thank you good on
you bro that's amazing yeah he was born
he was born two and a half weeks before
the Tony Ferguson oh wow wow yeah it's
very powerful what you just said because
all right so if you play in the NBA you
play the NFL the MLB hockey whatever the
soccer there's a game the next day the
next week the next yeah you go three six
nine 12 months without a w without a
fight yeah that's I mean in in wrestling
or UFC and boxing that's got a way on
you more than any other sport yeah right
it is it is very it is very tough it is
and that's I think that's the hardest
part about it and also from a longevity
standpoint you do take a loss no matter
what we need even if I went in there and
got caught in a submission it was just a
choke or something somewhat benign and
didn't take a lot of damage in the first
30 seconds I still went the last eight
ten weeks sparring two three times a a
week and I'm taking damage I'm taking
damage right now before the the fight
even happens and I've gotten very I
think very methodical and smart about
how I train who I train with the
training partners that I go with I'm not
going to say oh hey this is a brand new
guy who's a world champion kickboxer
from Amsterdam let me go ahead and test
myself yeah I don't need to test I I've
done my tests people know I'm tough
people know I I swing I swing and I'm
fine uh I'd rather be training in a safe
manner with a smile on my face in
not in that fight or flight mode and be
thinking about it and then when I get in
there once again going back to I can
trust myself and know that I can pull
that guy out of me well if you need a
sparring part where you're in Florida
Vinnie yeah it's available I know he
wants to do stands as well
if you want to practice your naked show
I'll just whatever imagine it's like no
just a little let me show you how it's
gone
yeah but this is this is a uh again
going back to it this is a big fight
yeah this is a this is a very big fight
for many different reasons you know both
from your end and his end uh it's
different point to prove on both sides
solving for different things on both
sides you know where he's going where
you're going uh it's gonna be so
interesting to see what strategy each of
you takes going into this one yeah I I
think fan base is excited fan base is
excited good for Dana for putting this
one together and from here it could be
very quickly by the way how soon do you
think Conor is going to come back how
soon do you think Conor will fight
I don't know I mean I was I was in the
you know I was obviously in the running
for that you know Connor coming back if
he was going to come back um there was a
lot of talk about me fighting him
obviously you know like God oh my God
yeah obviously you know I called him out
and everybody was talking about it he
even tweeted me I tweeted him back in a
very once again respectful manner which
is great you know
um but I think uh you know now he's
doing the road house remake with Jake
Gyllenhaal you know
um the uh the movie yeah the movie yeah
yeah I actually got I actually got
called about Patrick Swayze yeah
no no no no no no Jake Gyllenhaal is
playing Patrick Swayze Jake John was
great actor he's known Patrick Swayze
freaking kids Conor McGregor being the
Patrick Swayze yeah they're like who the
hell's the guy with the accent oh yeah
where did he come from yeah I didn't
think about that there's no irish guys
in the uh that's what I'm saying British
accents yeah he's gonna have to learn an
American accent because I mean I've been
following you know I follow you know
Connor's you know life and I mean since
the injury he looks like he's been you
know getting back to shape and he's
looking crazy but I mean he's drinking
and going out like a madman bro every
time I see him he's somewhere faded
drinking you know I know he's promoting
the job Justin called him out Justin
recently called him out he says look you
get to do everything I want to do
everything let's fight let's face each
other I'm good with that but you know
he's put on too much size where he's at
he's jacked he is Jack but listen that
guy right there
if he fought today everybody's buying
the paper you know out of the top five
biggest UFC fights uh Vinnie yeah do you
know out of the top five most
pay-per-views bought ever in the history
of UFC
you know who's in the top five how many
of the fights are his all of them
probably four out of five it's Connor
four out of five are here who's the
other one biggest pay-per-view you can
pull this article up pull it up biggest
most uh uh viewed pay-per-view most
viewed paper
uh Jose Aldo and him because that was
just the lead up with the UFC embedded
bro it was and con that that was the
first time that you saw Connor's uh like
trolling and talking crap and no guys it
may even be five for five yeah I think
it's I think it might be five for five
five four five yeah was I was Aldo the
first one that because that that tour
okay I'll just tell you right now here's
what a matter of fact it's not even five
for five check this out it's six for six
yeah okay highest one is him versus uh
uh uh khabib number two is Fortier two
number three is DS2 number three is 483
number four is Saron number five is
diaz1
and then seven is Usman mazwedal and an
eight is him Alvarez eighth is Mir
Lesnar nine is him Aldo yeah so so he's
seven out of the top ten fights ah you
got I mean pay-per-view ever yeah do you
this is this is insanity on what because
Usman is not a smackda it's not his way
to do when him and Kobe that want to
remember Kobe is sitting there in in the
uh you know after the fight and Usman
comes in and he's saying stuff to him
yeah Kobe can do it he can he can
talk smack Usman is he's a professional
if he came and you know he took the
fight in a different way this time the
last minute 29 whatever the time was
when he got he started backing up he
could have won that fight he's probably
so upset with that one but yeah usman's
still being who he is uh masvidel can
talk some smack and he'll sell tickets
uh but uh McGregor so
it's going to be interesting who he's
gonna fight when he comes back yeah I I
don't it's
it depends on where his mind where his
mindset is on you know what he wants to
do I mean Connor in the UFC as well the
UFC I mean I think he needs he needs to
he needs to come back and get a win if
he wants to continue to be Connor uh
does he need to be Connor anymore no I
mean obviously he sold his whiskey for
about 165 million I mean he's got he's
set for life you know
um 65 million is not a lot of money if
you depending on how you live yeah well
I guess guys
tell me why 100 165 football
not a lot of money if you go you want me
to tell you let's do the math I want to
know how many people are married
165 million how much taxes are you
paying on that
100 million plus left you got 120 left
okay you go buy 20 million dollar homes
left and right okay you go buy Yachts
you go party hardcore you go travel
private jet from here to Europe back and
it's a 500 000 flight if you go from
Europe to Vegas on a private it's 500
000 300 000 how many times can you do
that right there gas prices are going up
you can go with just with jet alone
that's 10 million in a year that's gone
believe me 165 million is not a lot of
money depending on how you live I'm
telling you right now it's not a lot of
money
I know guys who have a million bucks
that will have a million bucks 10 years
from now based on how they live and
they'll stretch a million
I know I know guys that got a few
hundred that they act as if they're
billionaires and you're not yet yeah
yeah so it's it's uh what you're saying
is mindset and basically your
expenditures yeah I don't know if he's
ever gonna fight the way he fought Diaz
won I don't think so I don't know if
we're gonna get a DS1 fight do I think
any fight he gets we're still gonna
watch it yes but you're not by the way
check this out look how crazy this is
look at crazy no no no just look at this
how many do you see there with khabib
one one what does that tell you
what do you mean no no he only has one
because the other guy he fought is
McGregor yeah so so so so it's either
you're extremely exciting yeah or you're
you know uh your your smack talker your
you know but it's got to be one of the
two like you know for example he sells
because he's extremely exciting yeah
Connor sells because he's just talking
but even khabib is not on this list 100
yeah without Connor just and they call
him the goat and he's not even on this
list because people want to watch a
exciting this whole thing with the cosmo
um how do you say I always screwed up
thumbs up right I think the case not
Middle Eastern and ice cream
okay so we were at his fight and he's
fighting a couple fights ago in
Jacksonville Frick boom good oh he went
up against your guy your buddy uh uh
when he was Gilbert Burns yeah by the
way no one thought it was going to be
that great but this guy was like wait a
minute Gilbert's the man you were with
Rogan yeah but no but this fight was a
fight right
he has uh you know he's a little bit you
know so it's going to be interesting to
see what happens here but if that guy
comes up comes back and fights I would
listen to me I would not illegally
stream that fight if he fought him you
wouldn't illegally you fight McGregor
I'm paying for that thank you you know
what I appreciate that what a lawyer man
this values but you really find out who
your friends are when they don't
illegally stream your fights
that's a friend he's about to say it's
the first time he's not gonna leave the
freaking thing yeah listen and I'm being
real I mean I'm vs but I'm definitely
paying for that but I think that and
this these stats Matt I mean he took
Connor took Ireland on his back and I've
never seen a fighter because I real talk
my friend Jade could attest uh for this
I was watching Connor when he was first
starting off and they were just
Whispering his name during bigger UFC
fights and I followed him I saw him bro
he put Ireland on his back and that's a
huge that the whole country shuts down
look at browser yeah look at Russia
homes that's when she kicked her and she
knocked her out right and Lesnar's
younger how many times three times good
for Lesnar look at that did you see
Brock Lesnar in college have you ever
seen him in wrestling it was it's a
spectacle like it was he was a Monster
yeah he was a monster did you see that
guy 20. 21 22 yeah yeah dude just Beast
like just it's a maniac he's that guy
when and you see him right here it's
like what is that not who is that what
is it but you got to realize look at
this the difference between him like
this guy has been fighting in fist fight
since he was a kid like he enjoys
something yeah he's he's a he's a you
know you know this the stuff he says in
in his interviews he's like man I've
been fighting my entire life yeah I like
a street fight you know I like to get
into it but you know it's it's a
difference I know Jackie is right there
with his coaches yeah that one right
there Tyler they'll go up up right there
this cat is just well the greatest thing
about the greatest thing about uh Brock
is that he was a legitimate College
wrestler you know exactly you know
obviously you can go the WWE route oh
it's it's you know scripted or it's this
and it's that but he this was him at
Minnesota from Webster's Webster uh
South Dakota dude won a national title
with the Gophers that's nuts well the
the school he went to was it a wrestling
school or Minnesota yeah Minnesota's
Minnesota is always usually top ten but
it was very cool when you were very cold
it's wrestling you know Minnesota you
know these types of places for Ohio they
produce wrestlers yep in Pennsylvania
State's now the number one because it
used to be Iowa for a while from yeah
Iowa's still you know always in the top
five Oklahoma States usually in the top
five
um where's your people in Mizzou and
that Mizzou were always in the top ten
usually we had a national champion this
year Keegan Mueller
um so yeah it's good and and and by the
way sorry Kiku no tool somebody's saying
right now saying Diaz was in the three
of those yeah you know three of the
seven so someone's trying to say like
Diaz was also Diaz's exciting 5 fighter
as well because he'll fight he's a dog
but it's selling tickets so he comes
back uh he fights you you guys well
that's gonna be a fight bro
it's gonna be a good fight man it'd be
fun that's gonna be a fun fight that's
going to be a fun fight if those two go
uh if the two of you guys go together
have you had any interaction with Connor
like have you guys spent time have you
guys talked or not necessarily no well
so we shared uh we shared a card I was
actually on I was on the Poirier too no
Poirier one no poor A2 I yeah because
they fought three times so I was on the
Poirier to UFC 257 that was my debut in
the UFC when I fought Dan hooker so we
shared uh we shared a press conference
when was that exactly that was January
23rd how long was it that fight was what
you remember where we were for that two
and a half minutes we watched it in the
house here in Boca we watched him fight
in the UFC at your house you just moved
into the house in Boca January of 20.
yeah we had just moved back you know
what I said what'd you say this guy's
one of the most exciting Fighters
This is the guy like the UFC you know
you want guys like this because people
are you you know what I what I don't
like about the NBA product today here's
what I don't like about the NBA product
today these guys let's just say you know
like I want to take the kids to go to a
game do you know I'm not interested in
taking it because I want to buy like a
quart size because I want to take the
guys to courts like the basketball game
right when the Lakers are coming down
here to see if they want to play Miami
or Golden State you don't want my
biggest concern is um yeah you know
they're resting that day just they're
just resting that they yeah there's no
such thing as fans in the in the NBA
they don't care about the fans during
the season right yeah NFL it's fan based
okay MLB they'd rest a little bit but
it's still fan base right UFC is all
fans guys like
Michael this is exactly what the UFC
Wants You know guys like Michael who
come and put on a show and people like
me are hoping the fight isn't in
November it's this Saturday but it's not
it's Saturday right we gotta wait and we
got some time five and a half weeks I
still got some back I still got some
training
yeah in Madison Square Garden yeah if
you guys wanted us to just listen if you
got early Christmas whatever I'll go
November 12. stream it I'll watch it
live see guys here's all I know 150
million bucks
they're so funny what do you think about
with Zuckerberg getting involved in the
UFC and what he's doing because that
when the video came out with Zuck I
don't I mean those that video is a real
video he didn't look like a you know
sometimes people show their videos like
they're boxing or training you're like
yeah you shouldn't have put that up like
Stephen A Smith one time put up a video
unboxing yeah and I hope he was just
trolling
everybody on Twitter went after him but
when Mark put it up you're like you know
what those kicks are real kicks yeah he
just doesn't move too bad at all man
zuck's got some hands and some kicks you
know who else does Wiz Khalifa you ever
seen Wiz Khalifa Wiz Khalifa or I don't
know if you can scrap but I mean he can
hit pads
yeah he's a tall lanky dude yeah like
you know when you when you just watch
guys so you Norm used to seeing
Zuckerberg like in his you know Facebook
attire or whatever and all of a sudden
he's you know throwing on gloves and
hitting pads and throwing knees and
kicks and low leg kicks are like what
the what yeah so how is he getting
involved you mean just kind of watching
or or is there something he wants to do
more with it you think there's uh I I
don't know I'd be interested to see what
Dana's perspective would be on on that
actually I don't know so what what is
the story he's been he's been kind of
invited to these private showings it's
not a private showing it was at the UFC
Apex which is somewhat private because I
think it only holds maybe 500 people or
so and you can go you can go I think you
can and buy a table and have a couple
people with you and watch the fights
yeah
um it's by no means a private event but
it's definitely not a you know a arena
show but there was reports that came out
because there was a girl named Mackenzie
Dern who I think was either the the main
event or the co-main event I think it
was the main event who said that
Zuckerberg rented out the whole Apex for
the show which I think turned out to be
not true oh really well allegedly let me
tell you something Michael Dana White
number one promoter out there in the
world when you're talking about hype and
Showmanship and just Pizzazz I'm
thinking Mark Zuckerberg guys
definitely not a human robot
confidence swag you talk about that
yeah I just got canceled yeah but you
know what you know what the to me you
know he went on Joe Joe Rogan and the
interview came out you know some stuff
that he said with FBI and all this other
stuff and then he's out there doing
stuff I think a part of him is like look
man I'm worth 100 billion dollars but
I'm living my life as well and I got
interest and I'm doing what I'm doing
and I don't know I like it I like seeing
what he's doing I like the fact that
he's out there doing what he's doing in
the water I like the fact that you're
here if he's not in
for an hour he's like I'm smoking some
meat smoking some ribs smoking like just
it's an hour if you're talking about no
no the weirdest strangest thing ever
weirdest is him I guarantee one of you
drove so you've probably seen it he's
testifying in front of Congress about
the privacy issues of Facebook and the
memes of him being a robot because he's
sitting like this Mike and I'm not
joking if you could pull up he it's like
almost a robot he goes
I have to drink this now it was the
weirdest drinking of water I've ever
seen in my life but but he also he also
had a mic drop moment which one was it
when they said so
so Mark uh how do you guys make money
okay we sell ads
and a guy's like oh okay and he goes to
the next person you don't remember this
whole mic uh when he says we sell ads
like why do you think we make money like
we have nothing else to sell our model
is selling ads and the guy had nothing
back to say to him by the way you know
how much money he's lost this year's net
worth has dropped 61 billion dollars
what do you think he's worth now
dude sell them five bucks I think he may
like need some money he's still worth
100 billion or no he's still probably
worth 40 billion he's probably the word
Pat I say this all the time
Facebook stock has gone down that much
or what yeah Facebook stock well a lot a
lot of the tech companies have taken
this week the great news when Elon Musk
announced that he's buying them all the
tech stocks went to the roof Twitter
blew up and it brought everybody else up
Facebook went up everybody went up this
week but uh uh uh Facebook's taking a
hit I think they they decided they
started a
news site like sub stack and they just
shut it down yesterday or today they
just shut down sub stack uh and meta
some stuff is going on with them that
they're trying to re-strategize and what
to do with the product but uh you know
he's uh he's he's definitely got a few
challenges ahead of him but you know his
product the product that he has is not
the product that it once was the moment
they changed the app of the advertising
side where it no longer kept track of
how you did advertising before and it
had to refresh because yeah that's even
that yeah Advertiser that changed the
game in a big way it messed with
everybody's ability to to track however
yeah exactly you know that was the whole
model about it though the whole thing
that was very appealing was you know if
I spend 100 Grand I can retarget the
people now I gotta start from scratch
again yeah unless that was a PR was
there was there some kind of privacy
issue deal going that's what it was
that's that was the whole thing okay so
they did it from the Privacy crazy you
know conspiracy question just throwing
it out there in the last 24 months
Zuckerberg you know Mr Robot himself
when before they changed Facebook to
meta right the epitome of joined the
matter you seen that commercial where he
did it was like you can come into the
metaverse and have an avatar
it was the most robotic commercial thing
ever but you know basically and then
since then
everything with meta nfts cryptos
obviously [ __ ] the bed yeah do you think
someone pulled him aside and was like
listen bro people legitimately think
you're a cyborg or a robot like straight
up like they actually think that start
doing some UFC stuff start cooking some
Meats get out there and start surfing
and maybe don't put so much sunscreen in
your face whatever just go be a human
yeah do you think someone actually said
that to him
I I don't know I I think
listen I think when you make money
and then you have Fu money times a
hundred like you know if you money is
what anything above
let's just say 100 million dollars got a
few money you gotta be above 165. yeah
we know that
live off of that no you could lose it
let me tell you a couple ways that goes
real quick all right listen hey have you
seen the price of fuel you go from
Europe outside
[Laughter]
so you're saying when you got [ __ ]
money no you know what I'm saying is I'm
saying do the guys how old is the guy
now is he 38 is he 30 30 late 30s early
40s 38 years old it's kind of like I
want to live a life this is what I want
to do bro like leave me alone bro I just
build a company I compete I got it big
I'm rich yes I got money and I'm pretty
powerful I still want to live a life I
don't want to be just this billionaire I
want to live my life I think there's a
part of it that's just more than life if
you constantly have to act for how the
World Views you dude that's a myth
you're a slave to the world it's not a
good life it doesn't matter how much
money they give you if you constantly
like by the way you know what's been
happening that you're seeing
is I think Elon started this trend I
fully believe it OnStar is this trend
because if you think about Elon Bezos
Zuck which one of them enjoys life the
most okay but that wasn't the case for
the longest time because he wasn't he
was so mechanical and he was so much
about then finally he's like listen man
I'm I'm freaking here's who I am I'm the
real guy from Iron Man and he's in the
movie like oh [ __ ] that's funny yeah
he's got a great senior here oh so this
guy's got a lighter side to me he's not
just a genius you know going through the
space type of guy and then he starts
trolling and he's taking shots at uh our
President Joe Biden and then Bezos is
like well why are people liking him more
than me maybe I can say something to Joe
Biden then Bezos did and then now Zuck
is coming out so I think what's happened
with all these guys is you know elon's
trying to say to these guys you can be
the richest man on the planet but you
still got to live your life and enjoy
yourself because he's going to die
eventually you're gonna live forever so
I think they're all kind of learning
from each other like whatever space
you're in you're gonna look get another
Pacesetter in your world to see what
they're doing and the Pacesetter in this
world is musk today and kind of
following his lead now I really agree
here's a real question here's a real
question
say Dana's able to pull this fight off
Jake Paul Bezos and Zuck
the biggest pay-per-view of all time for
sure
tops that list
they sent one tweet next thing you know
paper review
29.7 million buys you know okay so let
me just ask you right up from Bezos
against Moscow wins musk musk serious I
don't know I don't really know what I
don't know what Bezos
like much better yeah how tall is musk
though he's a tall dude bro Jeff Bezos
that lie really bothers me though I
gotta tell you a weird creatures you
were saying this about uh musk Bezos has
been having a lot of fun lately
he's working out he's you know he's
banging on a new chick you know how much
it how much it is his ex-wife married
who married the school teacher she just
divorced him yeah
there was a question of they had a
financial agreement and then she was
looking at shape man yeah that's what
I'm saying Basil's against musk yeah
he's got some some girth to him yeah
what musk on the boat when he had the
same sunscreen as uh Michael you can't
say when a guy's weren't in his shorts
it was an awkward moment
he's thick because I feel like thick
yeah comedy today's podcast went from
UFC good shape dude musk is not but I
think that's good it came out he started
changing his act though
yeah okay so so so Bezos Moscow wins
you're saying Bezos I'm saying as far as
looking uh as who's got the shape who's
got the girth
Bezos is in better shape than it yeah I
stand corrected on that yeah I thought
Elon was a little bit sore so then so
then let's put Zuck against Jeff who
wins basil well it's hard because Zuck
we've actually seen throws that's what
I'm saying zuck's got youth zucks 38. so
uh Bezos is what in his 50s
okay so I guess the the battle of the
billionaires sucks coming up I let the
Battle of billionaires
Zuckerberg would have like a little
computer he's a robot dude they would
upload some fighting [ __ ] like Matrix I
need to beat the [ __ ] out of him
battle the billionaire throw Warren
Buffett in there how do you think
by the way so you you were ranking the
top current uh 10 fighters in your
division right I saw you doing okay and
I think that you were doing that in your
opinion who's the top five you know
goats of all time like you know forget
to wait forget if they're retired forget
anything who's top five for you this
one's hard because I I am very
conflicted on Jon Jones because of the
the failed drug tests I feel like once
you've once you've failed a drug test
you somewhat pull yourself out of the
goat talk
um but I feel like Jon Jones is the most
dominant fighter of all time with the
asterisk of he has failed some drug
tests by the way what drugs did he was
he I don't know it was some kind of
performance enhancements and I mean I
think that and I mean he was he's openly
parties he's yeah well and I'm I'm not
okay with that I don't condone that but
that's but I also look at that
separately
yeah
um I think the I think the best
oh my God
we've lost control of this podcast
the best fighter of all time is that
whatever that guy is [ __ ] talker that is
hilarious but hang on guys keep going
yeah well with an asterisk but
I would put over top over him would be
George St-Pierre because of the way he
carried himself he did have some losses
like Jon Jones is essentially undefeated
he's never lost he lost one fight by DQ
um I think
um
I do
wow I didn't like that though I like
that well I think just because I think
GSP I mean maybe maybe it was because I
shared the same weight class and at the
same time as Habib so I didn't look at
him as much of a legend like I do like
when I was coming up and I was in in
college I was watching George St Pierre
versus Matt Hughes and all of these
other guys and the sport has evolved
obviously over the years
um
habib's strength of schedule compared to
George Saint Pierre's I think they're
pretty pretty similar but I would put
George as number one I would put Habib
as probably
number two Anderson Silva
number three
and then
um
I'm a DC guy I love DC you know DC
essentially only really lost to Jon
Jones and I think he lost to
who else maybe one other fight Cormier
yeah he just got into the Hall of Fame
too right yeah DC DC will be in my top
five
um you got one more got one more dang
I'm really I'm really not good he took
John out yeah I mean I I gotta take John
out John Jones
Cormier and you said Anderson Silva
Anderson Silva yeah but John's not in
there John's not I'm looking at what
he's saying I can't I can't play John
you got one in mine oh doggone I don't
know uh honestly
jail piece on it I loved it now I mean
from like greatest fighters of all time
from record and winning world titles and
all that kind of stuff but when it comes
to the full package of hey yeah I mean
you could put like a Nate Diaz type of
guy in there where it's like hey Diaz
fights we're watching who do you put as
a showman showman outside Connor's at
the top but who do you put on uh showman
showman would be chair will be number
two Diaz is number three
Diaz is not a showman Diaz isn't even
trying to be a showman he just looks
like a showman to so many people because
he that's is who he is I mean which is
so great good good for him he can just
be authentically whoever he is the young
man yeah and like smacking people and
you know smoking throwing water bottles
yeah you know you know Connor's doing
what he's doing it's yeah you gotta love
those guys though the Diaz brothers yeah
by the way I who's better out of the two
brothers
uh well
I don't I mean Nick Nick was great in
his in his Heyday and Diaz became a huge
huge name obviously because of the
Connor fights and then the last couple
fights with you know miles and he's Nate
is now surpassed Nick I believe but Nick
was for a long time he was he was Nick's
little brother that's all it was for a
long time
the gang leader is you know it's the
older brothers yeah it's not Nate yeah
so yeah they call the Nick Diaz Army
yeah that's right Nick Diaz yeah like
then and Nate still says that which is
cool I love that let me tell you I have
two sons I love seeing their level of
loyalty towards each other there's
something very uh special when you see
how loyal they are to you it's like The
Fat Joe thing you just posted yeah right
that's right yeah number two when he
talks about DJ Khaled yeah the level I
know how the meals to me like a number
two dude when you're screaming like that
you got a preface
in the back
okay so the showman we got the showman
uh in place by the way you know uh one
thing about uh
UFC which you know I'm curious to know
what what take you'll give on this one
uh in the NBA uh if you were to ask
politically where people are at in the
NBA you know it's like 99 when they say
we're taking the the voting day off to
go vote is because everyone's voting one
side right it's not that free for you to
take whatever position that you want and
what you're doing right
MLB I think it's pretty even Steven
people are to themselves nobody cares I
don't even think politics is an MLB
which is great because you watch
baseball you just watch baseball you
don't know nothing about people's
political you know leanings where
they're at NFL got more political
Kaepernick what he did Rihanna now is
apparently not doing a halftime Super
Bowl because of Kaepernick I don't know
if you saw that or not was she saying no
she's doing it she's doing it or she's
not doing it she's not doing it why just
just look at the story I saw she is or
she's not something came up saying she
is something came up she's not maybe she
is if she is now great
um but she wasn't going to because there
was something with Kaepernick that the
conversation was that it's not going to
happen uh go to Kaepernick if you type
in Kaepernick you'll see how uh uh Go to
stories
no it's not is it that one I just
couldn't be a celeriana once turned down
Super Bowl Halftime oh shoot once turned
it down okay and now she's coming back
because they said she's the first
billionaire to ever perform at the
halftime of the Super Bowl great awesome
so it's great to see that taking place
but UFC you know and you you've been to
you've been to CPAC I think you've been
to you've done some stuff if you did
that in the NBA dude you may be traded
to a Puerto Rican basketball league if
you would do something like that or you
you'd be playing in in Italy or
something if you did that uh uh how how
important do you think it is on the way
Dana runs it where it's like listen to
each his own I don't care where you
stand here's where I stand and I don't
care whether you like me or not I think
the other day was a Talking Carl Tucker
Carlson I want to say he spoke at the
RNC and it's as if he's bulletproof and
they can go after him there's something
about Dana that others can do what Dana
does and they're being you know going
through whatever they're going through
but now when it comes down to Dana do
people behind closed doors say look man
you just don't mess with the guy because
he's too connected is it the respect is
it the way he handles himself why do you
think UFC's left alone when it comes
down to politics
um I think because I think because there
is no politics in it for for one right
now we can we are independent
contractors we can talk about have
whatever we can talk about what we want
support who we want
um talk about politics as much as we
want talk about you know obviously you
need to with especially with the way
today is you need to watch yourself what
you say I mean you can't can't be over
the top with things but I mean we are
all independent contractors and a lot of
us are a lot of us come from very
similar backgrounds when it comes to you
know I mean we we I don't think most of
us ever thought about becoming you know
now you might have these younger guys
but I mean when some of these guys in
the NFL they've been dreaming about this
since they were 11 years old and they
wanted the 60 million dollar contract
and the 30 million dollar contract they
want to be playing for the Seattle
Seahawks I think a lot of us came from a
place where it was like
oh I got into fighting but I never
really thought about making getting on a
30 million dollar contract like kind of
crazy money
um so I think we just all come from very
similar backgrounds
um and we are I don't know in
we are individuals in an individual
Sport and we are all independent
contractors as well so individual and
individual sports and you're all
independent contract no so so I think
there is a little bit more of uh you
know there's we have a team I have a
great team here that I train with but
they're they're my team but it's not
like I'm playing for the Golden State
Warriors it's not like I'm playing for a
team you know
yeah but then I don't know if that
answers your question yeah but but then
for me it would be like if you're on the
team you know you would need to be more
diplomatic you know where they're not
they're more vocal versus UFC it's kind
of like look here's who we are we're
just you know they did the something
with the flag right where at one point
you couldn't bring bring the flag
something happened with the flag
Association I don't know what that was
that just happened and um year and a
half ago 14 months well it just happened
during the during the Ukraine Russia
right thing you know so I think
essentially they essentially they knew
there was going to be some kind of
backlash I believe hey if a Russian guy
comes in carrying a Russian flag during
this war time War a Ukrainian comes in
carrying don't do it no Flags whatsoever
which was sad for me because I love
carrying the American flag but I love
that but once again what am I going to
do yell at the equipment guy no it's not
his fault it was Dana's decision or it
was wme's decision or it was good to get
those things early on to say we're gonna
keep this out we're just gonna fight
yeah but here's the thing he'll do that
there's no flags and then he'll go and
talk across okay here's where I'm here's
where I stand here's what I'm thinking
what do you mean remember when Colby
Covington won in 2020 and Trump called
him while he's getting an interview he
looked like like a kid in Christmas you
guys that was a and you didn't see this
yeah I'm just like dude I watched the
fight it was against was it who was
against anyone it was an insane fight
Mike and Trump called him while he's
live on an interview and was just like
talk about politics I mean the president
United States called you to
congratulations oh no I mean Dana
brought Trump to a fight 100
fights yeah he was on the Air Force One
together and the Santos was at the UFC
fight in Jacksonville and he showed up
to the fight but it's it's a bulletproof
organization you know and I think again
to create that climate it's not easy to
do today no it's a very tough climate to
create but he's created that climate
where he allows his players to fighters
to do what they want to do yet at the
same time they still follow a protocol
it seems like there is a protocol
and then you're still free the protocols
just don't don't mess up don't don't
mess up don't get canceled don't say I
mean there's there's been guys who have
said certain things and gotten in
trouble for what they have said yeah you
know but they were they were out of line
just like any just like if you're an
artist you can get you know you can say
something and get in trouble just like
if you're a uh an athlete on one of
these other things I think you know you
look at the NFL and then you see
you see the things that are printed on
the NFL uh on the on in the end zones
and you see the wearing things on their
helmets and whatnot I don't know if they
were then there's a certain pressure to
well if I just wanted to be blank yeah
do I get do I get you know looked down
upon because you know it's to me that's
it's uh I mean if they Dana would never
do that he would never say hey there I
really like this cause so I'm gonna make
everybody wear this certain thing you
know every now and every now and then
maybe something pink for breast cancer
awareness or like something like that
they do these different initiate
initiatives and all that kind of stuff
but when it comes to politics and
especially now what what is what is the
climate it's just become so Bonkers and
it's and it's the flavor of the week and
it continues to change so hey what do
you you're going to implement something
right now that's going to be different
two weeks from now anyway or it gonna
get gonna be debunked or proven to be
false or whatever you know and then now
now with the with the elections coming
all that crap that was happening back
it's gonna start it's revving up again
bro trust me in two years November's
coming but in in two years of natural
election happens by or whoever's going
to run Democrat Republican watch what's
going to happen but I tell you what I
don't think UFC is going to be affected
by it I don't think so either I don't
think about it UFC wasn't even affected
by covet that's that's what I'm saying
we were the only sport on television yes
six months you set the tone that's it he
was uh he and and by the way you got
market share that's the point because
you know fans are sitting there saying I
need to see some kind of competition I
need to see competition show me
something with competing and you're
watching these basketball games you're
like all right so he goes down and uh
scores a layup and then he comes coming
back okay like is there any fans
screaming booing no and they put these
fake cutouts
you could do videos I'm like what this
is silly stuff like Adam you you're okay
with this kind of stuff on what they're
doing and then NFL's playing in open
Arenas and soccer remember soccer you
could hear every person speak very
awkward
every Nuance it was weird were you gonna
say something big part of it is the fact
that Dana's not a coward he doesn't bend
the need whims of anybody what does
Roger Goodell do the first thing he does
is battling and beg for forgiveness
right what does Adam Silver do the same
thing you think Roger Goodell's players
respect him you think LeBron James
LeBron James respects Adam Silver of
course not Dana's Fighters respect him
and they're smart enough not to say
anything stupid they're smart enough not
to get him in trouble and to listen to
what he has to say because they respect
him and Dana stays alive and it's a
bulletproof organization because he's
not going to bend the knee no matter
what he does or what he says right he's
not going to cower to these people you
you gotta you gotta love it by the way
Vinnie and I are both Assyrian what do
you think about beniel dariush I think
he's great good good fighter he fights
uh October 22nd yeah so that he's on the
that main card of the Islam versus
Charles Oliveira he's good he's talented
um he's on a couple fight win streak you
know I think it's between a lot of
people would say between possibly me and
him for that next title shot if we both
come out with wins or maybe we have to
fight each other to get the next title
shot who knows but
[Music]
that that would be a sick fight that
would be a sick fight but you but you
could throw blows so but when's the last
time he fought though I don't know if he
his last time he fought was
um I was on the card it was it was May
of last year I believe he he fought Tony
Ferguson I would I fought Charles
Oliveira let me let me ask you
scheduling wise why hasn't he fought for
is it more often to get hurt he got hurt
okay he was supposed to fight Islam I
think in like April ish or sometime this
earlier this year Islam and that that
fight he got hurt so that fight got
scratched and now Islam got the title
shot so
so now he's uh Mateo's camera and I
think he's fighting there's another guy
who's kind of surging in from the
outside the top 10 or around number 10.
your your you know category where you
guys are at there's a lot of beasts in
your uh weight class right now it's
going to be interesting to see what
happens uh final thoughts here on this
before we wrap up oh you're friends with
Woodley your friends would ask her and
you know everybody would say hey both of
them took a dive with the fight
yeah the Jake Paul fight what are your
thoughts on that I I don't know I
honestly haven't talked to either of
them about it I don't think it's
probably it's probably a sore subject
for both of them
um
I don't think it was a dive I could be
wrong no I don't know why watching Jake
because now you know people were
criticizing him first fight second fight
third fight so you're kind of like
saying this guy kind of knows what he's
doing and he's training and he's kind of
do you think he's got a trajectory or do
you think Silva's gonna expose him and
it's going to be like no this is it it's
done with I think he has a trajectory I
think he's very young in the sport I
think it it's still you can be you can
be
you can be somewhat critical of the fact
that yes he has not fought any high
level boxers whatsoever and also sing
his Praises that he does look pretty
decent for a guy who is going out there
and fighting he's he can move he he can
move he's got fast hands he's bigger
than I he's much bigger than I thought I
didn't know how big I've never seen Jake
Paul did not doesn't follow him until
these last you know couple years in a
couple fights and you see him standing
next to Anderson Silva towering over
Tyron Woodley towering over Ben he's a
bigger guy than I thought
um so he's big it's 200 something pounds
so I think uh I still think Anderson
Silva beats him but I also thought
Tyrone would beat him I thought Ben
might be able to beat him so and this is
purely boxing they're not they're not
doing any MMA but is what's his name uh
Anderson Silver is not a boxer though
right uh he's boxed a couple times now
he boxed uh what Julio Cesar Chavez Jr
son son the son which by the way he's at
one point it was nasty oh no question
yeah he has hands bro yeah
Ortiz I just with my because I get it
they're fighting older people that are
you know done and it's not even though
they're not boxers the the fact that
they were they were hinting at going to
the MMA I would I would love to see them
fight somebody in the mm like if they
switch to Europe like not UFC but you
know what I mean try to fight somebody's
gonna put your hands on you they would
they wouldn't last I don't think they
would last 30 seconds in a fight with
like an MMA fighter forget it but that's
everything Jiu Jitsu boxing wrestling
they there's nowhere to run in that cage
bro I would I would agree with you but I
would add a caveat to it okay here's
what the caveat is
ish
never bet against somebody with a big
chip man like if the if there's a chip
and the willingness to get in there and
you know improve
you know so there's yeah there's certain
people that that do really well with
that chip there's certain people that
love the fact that everyone's like
thinking he's going to lose 90 of people
besides this couple you know not couple
of his his large contingent of YouTube
followers or whatever all of us think
he's not going to be good he's going to
lose to this guy he's going to lose to
that guy he loves that both brothers are
athletes yeah you know and some of the
some of the best people in the world in
any business they do well with you not
thinking they can pull it off they're
weird like that the average person is
going to be like yeah maybe you do have
a point you're right I don't think I
can't beat them oh [ __ ] they're right
I'm not going to win this fight and
versus some are like what did you say
yeah oh really okay can you record that
video and put it on my screen saver on
my phone I wanted to every time it rings
I want it to be his voice saying what he
just said right there yeah yeah and
every time the phone rings I don't think
he can beat them hey Mom what's up
why are you pissed something because
they said I can't beat them every time
you come honey I just want to check on
you is everything good you know what's
hilarious I think Jake is in that camp
and I think his brother's in that camp
but we're gonna see we're gonna see
what's gonna happen there I think it's
gonna be a show so I talked to uh the
CEO of speed I talked yeah yeah and I
told him I said let's listen really
impressive guy young guy what he's done
where he's at and now you're doing
business you got this right here what is
that tell us tell us about cram cramp so
the cram is uh the PB and J reinvented
sprouted 100 sprouted
absolutely Blackberry or strawberry
I like them both equally but this one
this one has 19 grams of protein that
one has 13. what what's good flavor on
that one the black one no it's cold yeah
they're cool
yeah so we just launched uh Nationwide
in Sprouts did you try one already or no
and I know yeah I know you you got four
kids right so it's like it's it's like
the old uncrustable except much better
more neutrally nutrient dense mineral
complex and the fact that you don't have
the crust on it I don't like crust this
is perfect and actually there is your
peanut butter a little bit Frozen still
oh this is delicious
you literally just launched this yeah so
well we just launched in Sprouts so so
my all all organic oh this is this is
amazing oh my gosh
I like that it's cold on the inside too
yeah that's dope yeah so they come
Frozen and then it's actually I feel
like they're kind of in at that perfect
moment where that peanut butter kind of
tastes a little bit like peanut butter
ice cream yeah dude but you can also
take them in there you can thaw them out
you can throw them in your bag
you also toast them so it's hot on the
outside dude a little bit cold on the
inside sometimes I have not had a PB J
in years but yeah it's a strawberry or
uh but Mike and I'm being I'm being dead
serious it if it was like a competition
and people like which one which one is
the protein one which is the I cannot
tell the difference from this from a
regular PBJ that somebody did put in the
freezer in case it doesn't taste like
you added stuff in it to make it healthy
but this this is off the chain bro this
is dope that's good yeah like no sugar
added to the to the Jelly because that
was I'm a father of two I want my kids
to wow at least try to get some good
nutrients in them when they can
so these are a perfect little snack for
on the go and and then even you know in
my other other things that I'm doing so
Dustin poirier's got the hot sauce yeah
you got the PB and J B and J baby wow
I love it I hate the whole thing I got a
fitness app launching I'm hungry on
speed fit
a lot of stuff you're awesome you're
you're out there hustling and and you
know what I try to do with going back to
the UFC one of the biggest pain points
for the UFC is that every single fighter
only relies upon their UFC paycheck
so they are they are
enslaved to that UFC paycheck which then
creates tension between them and the
promoter hey fight me more give me more
money
where I want to be more of a
self-starter and be a guy who can
provide for my family outside of
just mixed martial arts just competing
inside the Octagon because I'm going to
hang those gloves up eventually right
that's the whole point is that
eventually you're going to have to
transition walk on walk on Fitness my
fitness app will carry me on into that
and cram and speed and some real estate
stuff and
you know I love it and then one day you
know when you get that 165 million
then I can almost make it because let me
tell you how fast it goes
you're gonna be oh you gotta live off
that cram all right what's good
oh yeah I was just trying to make a
small little analogy here and now we're
gonna let you live that down dude this
is insane no I really I really like it
do you have the link or you don't have
the link put it in the chat and also put
in the description that is amazing guys
I I dare you to go try it and order one
and you'll see how at least the
strawberry one I just had is amazing I'm
gonna take that with me to the house for
the family to try it uh dude you're
exactly who I thought this interview was
going to be you're freaking awesome
that's all I can tell you man I'm a I'm
a guy watching you from the outside from
the perspective of uh seeing how you're
carrying yourself also a fan you know
while you're fighting rooting you on
just want to see that Vision become a
reality that Journey neuron of one day
you know standing as the champion I
think about that one clip with the who's
the uh Hispanic guy maybe not today
maybe not tomorrow but one day but I
hope and I'm like man what you know that
feeling to say one day this is gonna
become a reality that high to hold that
up not because of the checks or the
payday but the fact that it was part of
the original and I think as a fan I'm
I'm looking forward to witnessing that
day and matter of fact when that fight
is set up I'll be Courtside we're in a
walk-on shirt just to represent you no
because you know when I say Courtside I
mean watching YouTube and then and then
I'm flying back with you to Florida
right here yes one million five weeks
from now yeah November 12th I believe is
it is yeah the day after Veterans Day
we're all gonna watch a fight at your
house unless you're going there on a
private jet or something like that
why are you counting us out of this
house situation I'm good we're gonna be
there okay
I think the next one is tomorrow morning
at 9 00 a.m we'll see you guys piss off
a lot of people tomorrow I'm talking
about that one's gonna be a little wild
but anyways have a good one everybody
we'll see you guys tomorrow take care
bye bye bye bye